bonjour à tous alors que plus de 12
millions d'élèves F en rentré et leur
grande rentrée scolaire aujourd'hui je
vous propose de revoir cet après-midi
une table ronde sur la réforme du
collège avec les représentants des
syndicats de direction et d'inspection
table ronde organisée ici au Sénat au
printemps dernier alors hier nadjad
valobelkassem a réaffirmé la volonté du
gouvernement de bien mettre en œuvre
cette réforme dès la rentrée 2016
plusieurs points continuent de poser
problème en particulier la suppression
des classes bilangues car les collégiens
apprendront une langue étrangère dès la
5e la ministre de de l'éducation estime
même qu'un malentendu s'est installé
avec les syndicats d'enseignants au
sujet de cette réforme du collège les
syndicats d'enseignants se réunissent d'
d'ailleurs cette semaine pour décider ou
non d'un mouvement de grève dans le
courant du mois de septembre tout de
suite donc je vous propose de voir cette
table ronde alors je vous propose de
commencer ce tour de table je propose de
commencer par Monsieur Michel Richard
pour le Syndicat national des personnel
de direction de de l'éducation nationale
ne voyez aucune hiérarchie dans l'ordre
des prises de parole c'est parce que ça
se trouve comme ça sur mon papier donc
donc
voilà
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrices mesdames chers collègues
d'abord tous nos remerciements pour
cette invitation nous sommes toujours
très sensibles au fait que les la
représentation nationale nous sollicite
et demande à entendre notre avis alors
le snpdn le Syndicat national des
personnels de direction de l'éducation
nationale comme sa fédération l'UNSA
Éducation a voté pour cette réforme au
Conseil supérieur de l'éducation qui l'a
d'ailleurs très largement adopté par
plus de 58 voix pour contre une
vingtaine de voix contre l'analyse que
nous portons sur cette réforme est la
suivante cette réforme elle parachève
les précédentes plutôt qu'elle ne va
profondément bouleverser l'organisation
du collège ce que nous approuvons tout
particulièrement dans cette réforme
c'est le fait
que le collège est pris
en examen par rapport à sa situation
actuelle qui ne donne satisfaction à
personne ni aux enseignant ni aux
parents ni au pays puisque les élèves il
rencontrent soit des difficultés soit
n'arrivent pas à obtenir les résultats
auxquels ils aspirent alors dans cette
réforme il y a un point qui nous paraît
absolument intéressant et fondamental il
s'agit de la possibilité de une part
d'autonomie à l'établissement et
j'insiste beaucoup sur à l'établissement
puisque il y a eu des dérives disant que
c'était un chèque en blanc signé au chef
d'établissement il n'en est absolument
pas question il s'agit de l'autonomie de
l'établissement c'est 3 heur par classe
vont permettre dans le respect d'un
cadre national auquel nous sommes très
attachés de définition des horaires des
programmes des certifications va
permettre aux établissements d'adapter
leur offre de formation
aux besoins propres de chaque
établissement puisque il y a environ
8000 plele lycée collège et lycée
professionnels dedans il y a environ
6000 collèges et bien évidemment il y a
une énorme diversité entre chaque
établissement l'autre point important
dans cette réforme qui nous séduit c'est
le concept de
fongibilité horaire entre les
disciplines au sein des qure années du
collège là encore il s'agit d'une marge
de manœuvre donc une marge d'autonomie
laissée au aux établissement quelques
points que nous souhaiterions voir
approfondis dans les prochaines semaines
ou les prochains mois avant la mise en
œuvre de la
réforme nous nous pensions qu'il était
préférable de définir les curriculas
avant les horaires en effet il nous
semble important de préciser ce que
doivent connaître maîtriser les élèves à
l'issue de la scolarité collège qui va
terminer le socle commun de connaissan
et de compétences et donc à partir du
moment où on définit ni ces curricula on
aurait pu déterminer les horaires c'est
une démarche différente qui a été
choisie le deuxème point sur lequel il
nous semble utile de devoir se pencher
c'est la question du temps de travail de
du collégien ce temps de travail du
collégien il se réparti en en temps de
présence dans l'établissement mais
également en une part importante de
travail de manière personnel et on voit
là que ce
creuse se situe un creusé d'inégalité
forte alors je vais l'illustrer très
rapidement entre le collégien dont la
maman et le papa sont professeur ou
exerce une profession libérale qui a la
possibilité quand il rentre à la maison
de pouvoir se faire aider sur tout ce
qu'il n'a pas compris et se faire
assister pour faire le travail personnel
et puis l'enfant dont la maman est
technicienne de surface elle part à à
16h ou 17h lorsque l'enfant rentre elle
revient à 22h elle repart le lendemain
matin à 5h du matin cet enfran est livré
à lui-même il y a là donc quelque part
quelque chose sur lequel nous pensons
qu'il est nécessaire de se pencher si
l'on veut véritablement faire bouger le
concept et les modalités de
fonctionnement du collège et puis le
dernier point concerne une réforme
profonde des modalités d'évaluation des
élèves nous souhaitons et nous l'avons
déclaré depuis de longues de longues
années déjà l'abandon de l'école du tri
le socle commun de connaissance de
compéten et de culture qui va du CP à la
classe de 3e doit être parce que il est
dans le cycle de l'école obligatoire
doit donc bien être pour tous les élèves
et il ne pour il ne peut être question
pour nous de continuer à mettre en place
un système qui va déterminer et
sélectionner de manière très tôt des
élèves alors que nous pensons que la
maîtrrice du socle commun est
indispensable pour les futurs citoyens
qu'ils vont être dans quelques années
voilà en quelques mots ce que je
souhaitais vous présenter merci merci de
votre concision je donne la parole à
votre voisin monsieur donc la fac qui
représente le syndicat indépendance et
direction madame la Présidente Mesdames
les sénatrices mieurs les sénateurs
mesdames Messieurs Je m'associerai
évidemment au remerciement présentés par
le collègue Richard pour le fait de
d'être entendu ce qui n'est pas ce qui
est toujours utile en tant que personnel
de direction par le représentant
nationale par la représentation
nationale pardon la réforme du collège
agite les esprits nourrit les
conversations occupe les médias depuis
de longs mois et les interrogations des
personnels de terrain notamment des
personnels de direction ne s'apaisent
pas indépendant ces direction considère
comme légitime l'évolution du collège à
forceie quand les niveaux qui le suivent
ou qu'il précède ont été réformés
pourtant nous réfutons l'idée du maillon
faible du système éducatif car nous
estimons que s'il est loin d'être
parfait le collège n'a pourtant pas
failli dans l'ensemble de ses missions
et notamment dans celle de la
massification notons à ce sujet que
c'est l'Observatoire sur les inégalités
en France qui affirme dans un rapport
publié au début de ce mois que l'école
n'aggrave pas les inégalités même si
elle ne réussit pas à les réduire ce qui
est pourtant nous en convenons et nous
en sommes tous d'accord son
objectif sans doute l'évolution de la
société des techniques de
l'environnement comme de la pédagogie
rendre la mutation du collège nécessaire
et nous sommes tout prêts à participer à
cette démarche dans une société où
l'école est un enjeu sur lequel chaque
enfant chaque citoyen chaque responsable
chaque élu a un point de vue tant il est
vrai que chaque âge de la vie a un lien
avec l'école nous interrogeons cependant
sur la situation du moment qui à travers
les études internationales tant à faire
prévaloir un modèle plutôt
anglo-saxon qui ne coïncide pas toujours
avec le mythe national de l'école laïque
et républicaine de la 3e république et
d'ailleurs qui objectivement souhaite
réellement voir proposer à nos enfants
une école de type Sud en pourtant bon
élève dans les
comparatifs un autre écueil que le
pragmatisme
invite pardonit excusez-moi un autre
écueil que le pragmatisme invite aussi à
éviter consiste à attendre que l'école
réforme la société certes l'école un
rôle une responsabilité dans la
construction du citoyen et donc de la
société mais ce rôle elle le partage
avec tant d'autres de la famille au
médias et aux différentes institutions
et l'école demeure aussi le fruit de
cette société et de ses attentes il est
normal que la société interroge l'école
mais la société doit aussi s'interroger
quand elle constate que trop d'élèves
peine à comprendre le sens de l'école la
chance qu'on a d'apprendre et un film
récent a été un succès sur le chemin de
l'école justement montrant bien la
différence entre nos nos élèves que nous
avons emmené parce que je suis principal
de collège voir ce film et d'autres
enfants dans le monde parce que l'effort
n'est plus considéré aujourd'hui comme
une valeur positive toute société doit
avoir confiance dans son école la
valoriser valoriser ses acteurs c'est
une condition de sa réussite et de son
efficacité à ID nous nous nous affirmons
comme des acteurs de terrain
responsables soucieux de la qualité du
service public offert aux élèves à tous
les élèves et nous avons le sentiment
que faute d'avoir clairement et
précisément défini les préalables et les
attendus la réforme du collège qui
cherche à concilier des visions parfois
contradictoires ne permettra pas en
l'état à la société de de retrouver la
fierté dans son
école le temps de cette intervention
étant par nature contraint je
n'insisterai que sur quelques points que
nous considérons comme saillant sur le
plan positif nous estimons que la mise
en place d'une réforme dont les
objectifs sont louable en jouant en même
temps sur les paramètres des programmes
et d'un nouveau socle était une bonne
base de départ le projet de réfléchir en
parallèle sur les méthodes pédagogiques
et les supports numériques notamment
était un autre acteur favorable mais le
tempo adopté vient ruiner cet édifice
car la réforme doit être mise en œuvre
sans avoir permis aux acteurs de
s'approprier ces éléments la rédaction
des programmes n'est pas achevée la
déclinaison d'item du nouveau socle
n'est pas réalisée mais en avance nous
nous inquiétons aussi de certaines
propositions de cette réforme si nous
sommes favorables à la possibilité
d'adaptation pédagogique pour répondre
aux besoins différenciés des élèves nous
considérons que cette autonomie des
établissements doit porter
essentiellement sur les rythmes les
méthodes les démarches pédagogiques
individualisé et non sur les contenus
qui doivent rester nationaux gage de la
formation équitable de tous les citoyens
quelle que soit leur origine
géographique ou sociale nous sommes
ainsi favorables à une autonomie exercé
dans un cadre national identique pour
tous nous n'hésitons pas non plus à
affirmer que la France a besoin d'une
élite et qu'il appartient à l'école de
la République d'accompagner et de guider
les élèves chaque élève surelon la
devise sitius altius fortius cher
cuberta fallaitil la citer en latin je
vous laisse juge parler temps qui court
le devoir de l'école n'est pas de
reproduire les élites mais de permettre
à chacun d'y accéder et une certaines
sections bilangue ou européenne sont
précisément des chemins de réussite et
d'excellence pour des collégiens qui ne
sont pas tous des
héritiers c'est pourquoi nous sommes
attachés à la mixité sociale dans les
établissements associés au our en grâce
de l'exigence car on n'exige que de ceux
que en qui l'on
croit nous ne sommes pas fort convaincus
que les formations d'excellence pour peu
que tous puissent effectivement être
accompagnés pour y accéder et y réussir
soit la vraie cause des disparités
constaté entre élèves à l'issue de la
scolarité
obligatoire nous redoutons même que
certaines familles ne quittent nos
établissements pour retrouver ces
formations d'excellence dans d'autres
réseaux dans d'autres réseaux aggravant
ainsi encore la situation sur le plan
pratique je m'arrêterai sur quelques
éléments qui nous semblent d'emblé et
techniquement des obstacle à la réussite
de cette réforme nous relevons ainsi une
contradiction entre l'affirmation de la
nécessaire acquisition de compétences
tout au long du cycle 4 validé par le
PER par le palier 3 du socle et le
maintien en parallèle du diplôme
national du brevet sensiblement sur les
bases
actuelles est-ce bien raisonnable et
cohérent je m'attarderai brièvement sur
un axe de la réforme dont nous avons le
sentiment qu'il est la généralisation
d'expériences tentées sur de petits
nombre les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaires dont les modalités
de mise en œuvre restent bien floues
relevons au préalable que les six
domaines à sélectionner valider et
auquels les enseignants devront donner
du contenu seront des sources
d'inégalité tant en fonction des équipes
que des conditions locales géographiques
ou
budgétaires l'absence de temps de
concertation institutionnalisé pèera sur
leur mise en vre
la manière dont les équipes
s'approprieront ces EPI ne manque ne
manquera pas de différer d'un point à
l'autre du territoire tant sur les
contenus choisis que sur la ventilation
des domaines au long du
cursus les premiers concernés seront les
élèves amené à changer d'établissement
par lesquels il sera fort compliqué et
même quasi impossible de repérer les
points qui n'auront pas été étudiés
cette évolution aggravera les disparités
entre établissements en terme d'exigen
comme de contenu qui vont se trouver
décuplés généralisé au détriment des
élèves et souvent des plus fragiles
l'histoire des arts sans horair sans
CADR aujourd'hui elle aussi dépendante
des choix d'équipe et dont nous
dénonçons l'aspect inégalitaire pour les
élèves dans le cadre du DNB on est une
preuve tangible en ce
moment sur le plan organisationnel les
établissements à Fort effectif seront
confrontés au problèmes de nombre et
d'espace tandis que les autres devront
compter avec les multiples postes
partagés qui sont autant d'éléments
d'inégalité à cela s'ajouteront aussi
les problèmes de postes qui
immanquablement viendront interférer
dans la réflexion pédagogique
particulièrement en période de baisse
démographique comme on connaissent de
nombreux
collèges ces paramètres ne manqueront
pas d'inciter les équipes à privilégier
tel ou tel domaine pour éviter la
fermeture d'un poste ou la création d'un
complément de service dans
l'établissement voisin est-on bien
certain que sur de si grand nombrees ce
sera l'élève le
gagnant il ne suffit pas de dire que les
chefs d'établissements seront les
garants de l'opération le rôle est loin
d'être clairement fini il n'est que de
constater le peu de place qu'il aura est
accordé dans les textes publiés voire
dans les projets à
paraître en terme d'organisation de
temps scolaire et j'en conclurai ici
notons encore que la prise en compte et
la combinaison des EPI à rythme anuel
semestriel trimestriel ajouté au
semaines interdisciplinaires aux
enseignements complémentaires risque se
traduire par des emplois du temps
particulièrement pour les élèves
particulièrement pesant pour les élèves
et je ne mentionnerai que pour mémoire
le travail supplémentaire induit pour le
personnel de direction qui sera
forcément au détriment d'autres missions
la rapidité avec laquelle cette réforme
doit se mettre en place en une seule
étape risque s'avérer un autre handicap
avec des équipes enseignantes perplexes
réticentes si ce n'est aussi hostile qui
devront toute l'année à venir et sans
réelle formation préalable se projeter
se montrer créative le climat a peu de
Chan de se révéler
propice en conclusion il faut rappeler
qu'indépendance et directions reste
avant tout attaché à une éducation
effectivement nationale de qualité et
qui se préoccupe de tous les élèves nous
regrettons le flou qui préside la mise
en place d'une réforme finalement
essentiellement structurelle qui
reposera Infiné sur les personnels de
direction qui ont fort peu été entendus
dans cette
démarche merci euh monsieur lafac euh
pour le sgenen
CFDT madame claudieayette vous avez la
parole
merci Madame et merci de nous avoir
invité vous avez déjà rencontré dans
l'audition des personnels enseignants
notre secrétaire général Frédéric SEV
mon propos sera peu différent puisque
dans le cadre du travail de notre
syndicat général la le travail sur la
réforme se fait entre enseignant et
personnel de direction je dirais d'abord
que la vie d'usgen CFDT est aussi qui
s'est exprimé au au Conseil supérieur de
l'éducation est aussi celui de
l'ensemble de notre confédération la
CFDT à l'ensemble ble des membres de la
CFDT siégeant au CSE se sont prononcés
favorablement sur la réforme euh d'abord
parce que euh les les éléments les
éléments d'appréciation que nous avons
sont portés sur une évolution quand même
qui euh est correspond à notre projet
social et à notre projet sociéal à la
CFDT c'estàd de vouloir effectivement
par rapport au constat sur le collège
unique qui a réussi certes la
massification mais qui n'a certainement
pas réussi sa démocratisation euh nous
nous voulons effectivement que que le
collège nous avons toujours souhaité que
le collège évolue il est peut-être pas
le maillon faible il est en tout cas le
maillon souffrant souffrant pour des
personnels souffrant pour des élèves euh
nombreux qui qui y échouent
euh en tant que principal de collège
j'ai toujours vu avec beaucoup de
difficultés les élèves arrivés en 6e et
très rapidement décrochés par la manière
dont est organisé dont sont organisés
nos collèges alors d'abord on a eu aussi
un avis favorable par parce que il y a
une vraie cohérence là entre la loi de
refondation qui donne pour objectif
clair à l'école obligatoire dont le
collège et la CYC le
terminal comme objectif l'acquisition du
socle commun de compétence de de de
connaissance de compétence et de culture
et qu'il a que la loi a enfin tranché
entre le rôle d'une école commune pour
tous ou d'un petit lycée où finalement
on était beaucoup dans le tri et la
filtration
successive il y a aussi une cohérence
qui est faite sur le la définition du
socle la définition des programmes et
actuellement ce qui est en train en
préparation sur la définition de
l'évaluation le projet collège pour le
Sgen Cfdt reprend également des choix
des propositions que nous faisons depuis
depuis longtemps auquel nous sommes
fortement
attachés la possibilité pour les
établissements d'avoir la main sur une
partie de l'élaboration de leur parcours
de formation c'est-à-dire que il y a
effectivement une partie des
enseignements qui doit être commun
nationaux il y a aussi pour atteindre un
certain nombre d'objectifs de
connaissance et de compétences la
possibilité de travailler en fonction
des ressources locales en fonction de la
réalité des élèves et en fonction de la
réalité des des des compétences
professionnelles des enseignants et ça
ça nous semble intéressant d'autre part
nous sommes aussi très attachés à la
possibilité de moduler les les
enseignements en fonction du cycle si
effectivement on veut véritablement
arriver à une on sait que les élèves qui
ne réussissent pas sont des élèves qui
par rapport à leurs apprentissages sont
freinés par le fait que ça va trop vite
pour eux et qu'on évalue
systématiquement en de manière
définitive les acquis des élèves en fin
de 5 dans dans le courant de la 5e dans
le courant de la 4e dans le courant de
la 3e ce qui ce qui freine énormément
les élèves dans leur réussite les élèves
en difficulté parce qu'ils n'ont pas on
leur donne pas le temps d'apprendre donc
nous sommes très attachés effectivement
à des possibilités de modularité dans le
cycle
euh cette réforme nous intéresse aussi
parce qu'elle considère les personnels
enseignants comme des cadres A experts
et pas des exécutants ce qui est souvent
le cas maintenant et même beaucoup
d'enseignants ont intériorisé l'idée que
il faut que tout soit défini par le haut
et nous ça nous intéresse effectivement
de rendre aux enseignants le pouvoir
d'agir sur véritablement les conditions
de leur organisation pédagogique parce
qu'elle donne aussi du Grand amoudre euh
en terme de de de marge de manœuvre au
conseil pédagogique nous nous avons
depuis longtemps milité pour que le
conseil pédagogique devienne un un outil
réel de réflexion des équipes
pédagogiques pour créer du collectif
dans les équipes d'établissement et ici
le conseil pédagogique retrouve dans les
textes un rôle et du entre guillemets du
grin mood la réflexion sur les EPI
l'utilisation des marges horaires tout
ça c'est quelque chose qui doit
permettre de développer du projet
collectif dans les établissement bien
souvent les démarches de projets dans
les établissements dans les collèges
sont à la pé perférie véritablement de
l'organisation pédagogique parce qu'on
on fait des projets qui sont un petit
peu Enus au-delà mais qui ne sont pas au
cœur des apprentissage pour nous il est
important que les démarches de projet
soient véritablement au cœur des
apprentissages parce qu'elle remet aussi
au premier plan un rôle prédominant des
des des cadres des cadres de de
l'éducation nationale en terme
d'accompagnement des équipes et ça ça
nous semble aussi très
important nous ne cachons pas cependant
nos inquiétudes sur les moyens qui
seront mis en terme de formation et sur
le temps qui sera donné aux équipes pour
mettre en place la le travail de
concertation et cette question n'a pas
été résolu véritablement par exemple ni
dans les textes concernant les missions
particulières qui pour l'instant sont
essentiellement données en en espèce
sonnante et triébuchante et pas en temps
de travail et ça c'est une un regret que
nous avons au niveau du Sgen Cfdt et sur
la capacité des équipes à se former
l'année prochaine voilà les les grands
points effectivement que je tenais à
souligner je dirais en dernier et en
conclusion que par contre bien
évidemment l'école n'est qu'un élément
de de notre cohésion sociale et que ce
qui peut se passer au niveau de la
réforme du collège ne dédoine absolument
pas ni l'État ni les collectivités
territoriales sur les moyens de mettre
en œuvre une véritable mixité sociale
dans les établissements mais ça c'est un
autre problème qui ne dépend pas de la
réforme du collège merci bien je je vous
remercie madame donc après les
représentants des syndicats des
personnels de de direction nous allons
entendre les représentants des syndicat
d'inspection donc je donne la parole à
Monsieur Patrick rouagnac qui va
s'exprimer pour le syndicat de
l'inspection de l'éducation nationale je
vous remercie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
faits sont étu c'est la première chose
qui vient à l'esprit quand on parle des
résultats du système éducatif en France
malgré les multiples réformes malgré les
nouvelles connaissances dans des champs
didactiques ou pédagogiques malgré les
les nouveaux outils au premier rang
desquels j'évoquerai bien sûr le
numérique notre école reste obstinément
plus efficace à garantir la reproduction
sociale qu'à aidé les plus fragiles à
mieux
réussir pourtant me direz-vous l'école a
joué autre fois le rôle d'ascenseur
social quelle belle image
dépinal l'ascenseur a toujours été
réservé au privilégiés le monde charge a
permis à de rares jeunes issus du peuple
de les rejoindre au prix de grands
sacrifices
la masse a pris l'escalier aux marches
toujours plus hautes et aux issues
incertaines n'oublions pas que
l'exception ne fait jamais que confirmer
la règle elle seule infin mérite d'être
connu pour comprendre le fonctionnement
d'un dispositif social c'est dans ce
contexte que nous a proposé une
opération qui puise sa légitimité dans
son aspiration à modifier en profondeur
le fonctionnement du système éducatif en
effet c'est bien dans une approche
systémique que s'inscrit cette réforme
du collège qui apparaît de ce fait comme
un réel espoir de mieux aider les jeunes
à réussir à l'école et plus tard à mieux
s'intégrer dans la société
elle est dans le droitfil de l'ambition
affichée dans la loi de refondation de
l'école et mérite mieux que les colibés
insensés que nous entendons depuis des
semaines et qui traduisent bien la
résistance d'un système social porté par
ces turifères enferm dans leur certitude
et leur confort
idéologique ce n'est pourtant pas d'un
débat politique dont nous avons
aujourd'hui besoin mais d'un véritable
débat
éducatif une alternative simple s'offre
à nous maintenir une structure qui a
prouvé son inefficacité à prendre en
compte les évolutions des jeunes et de
la société ou oser bousculer nos
habitudes en introduisant des pratiques
éducatives qui ont fait leur preuve dans
d'autres pays
cultiver notre pitoyable exception
française en construisant patiemment
l'échec scolaire et l'exclusion social
ou nous orienter résolument vers des
solutions plus audacieuses qui nous
permettront de faire
société ce n'est pas la première fois
que nous nous trouvons à la croisée des
chemins en
1975 nous avions la possibilité de
mettre en œuvre l'école fondamentale
digne héritière de la réflexion princeps
de wallon et V nous avions retenu alors
le modèle du petit
lycée pour un collège qui n'a jamais pu
devenir unique que dans les mots et non
dans les
faits puissions-nous ne pas réitérer
cette erreur car comme le rappelle
l'aphorisme si ERAR anouest persévérer
diabolicum
est à ceux qui se réclament de
l'élitisme République Iain pour défendre
ces ces modalités élitaires je rappel je
rappellerai simplement que cette
orientation prend ses sources dans la
pensée de condorsé et qui pourrait mieux
la synthétiser que Daniel conchéré quand
elle déclare que l'objectif de
l'éducation est que le plus grand des
savants et le plus modeste des individus
ayant reçu l'instruction élémentaire ne
soit plus séparé que par une différence
de degré voilà qui donne sens au concept
de socle commun des compétences des
connaissances et de la culture nous
sommes bien loin de l'idée de viatique
culturelle minimaliste souvent dénoncé
par ce même dont il est le fond de
commerce quotidien vous l'aurez compris
résolument avec ténacité et en totale
cohérence avec le projet sociétal de
notre fédération le S UNSA affirme et
soutient affirme son soutien pardon à
une réforme indispensable pour tourner
le dos aux dérives mortifères d'un
système éducatif qui exclut les jeunes
qu'il est incapable de comprendre et
d'aider nous soutenons que la réforme
conspuée par certains est pourtant le
seul espoir de redonner confiance à ceux
qui feront la société de demain ils
seront nous le savons tous confrontés à
des difficultés que nous ne faisons
qu'entrevoir et qui nous font frémir des
valeurs aujourd'hui
ringarde comme la solidarité seront
peut-être demain la seule voix possible
pour conserver l'espoir comment
pourrions-nous ne pas réagir aux propos
démagogi
de ceux qui ne disent pas après moi le
déluge mais plutôt après moi moi quelle
arrogance quelle fatuité certes ne
faisons pas l'erreur de parler de
pseudos intellectuels ce sont au
contraire de vrais de purs intellectuels
ce qui rend encore plus inquiétant leur
positionnement c'est en toute conscience
qu'il sacrifie l'avenir au passé
l'individu au système l'élève au savoir
c'est aussi en toute conscience que les
inspecteurs du S UNSA tournent le dos à
ses chimères et affirment leur soutien à
une réforme qui ne va peut-être pas
assez loin mais qui prend le bon chemin
je vous remercie de votre
attention bien je rappelle monsieur
rouagia que vous représentez le syndicat
de l'inspection éducation nationale
UNSA je passe la parole on va laisser à
Monsieur devin qui nous a rejoint il y a
quelques instants le temps de de
reprendre son souffle et je donne la
parole donc à Monsieur Claude Desfray
syndicat des inspecteurs
d'académie
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs merci déjà d'avoir accepté
d'auditionner le syndicat des
inspecteurs d'académie fort de la
connaissance des réalités des classes et
de l'expertise pédagogique des
IAPR le syndicat des inspecteurs
d'académie a adressé le 19 mai dernier
une analyse et des propositions à à
madame la ministre sur la réforme du
collège celles-ci ont été rendu publi la
déclaration de ce jour reprendra une
partie effectivement de ces propositions
en cohérence avec la loi du 8 juillet
2013 cette réforme prévoit la mise en
place de trois types d'enseignement
obligatoires l'enseignement commun
disciplinaire et deux enseignements
complémentaires l'enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire et l'accompagnement
personnalisé al off ainsi une palette
pédagogique variée permettant de
favoriser la réussite pour tous les
élèves nous ne pouvons que nous en
réjouir cette offre garantit à priori la
mise en œuvre de démarches pédagogiques
diversifié pouvant garantir
l'acquisition du socle commun de
connaissance et de culture par
tous pour autant sur le temps qui m ici
octroyé je m'attacherai vous exposer
comment cette réforme fragilise cette
ambition malgré la richesse de sa
diversité pédagogique pour cela je me
limiteré exprimer deux analyses l'une
concernant l'autonomie laissée aux
établissements l'autre concernant
l'interdisciplinarité prévue par
l'enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire EPI et la
pluridisciplinarité relevant de
l'accompagnement
personnalisé l'accroissement de
l'autonomie des établissements est la
marque de cette réforme selon l'arrêté
du 19 mai
2015 le choix sera laissé aux
établissements de définir SEP à H
paramètres tout d'abord l'articulation
des enseignements de 6e avec ceux des
deux autres années du cycle 3
deuxièmement l'organisation des
enseignements de sciences en 6e
troisièmement l'organisation des
enseignements artistiques sur l'ensemble
du cursus qurièmement l'organisation de
de l'accompagnement personnalisé
conduisant à une décision sur les
discipline devons y contribuer 5ièmement
l'organisation des EPI sur le cycle 4
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
donc conduisant à une décision sur les
disciplines devant y contribuer et les
deux thématiques retenues pour chacune
des trois années du cycle 6ièmement la
répartition horaire entre
l'accompagnement personnalisé et les EPI
pour chaque année du cycle 4 et enfin
7èement la répartition des horaires
entre les disciplines pour chaque niveau
du cycle c'est ainsi qu'au total pas
loin de SEP décisions distinctes certes
corrélé entre elles devront être prises
collectivement sur la base du la base du
projet d'établissement contre environ
une à deux
aujourd'hui alors on constate
effectivement que à défaut d'une solide
formation en ingénierie pédagogique et
un temps de concertation dédié cette
plétor de
concertation
organisationnelle risque de détourner
les enseignants du cœur de leur métier
et d'induire des tensions source de
souffrance anxiogène peu favorable à une
proche coopérative des apprentissages
des
élèves ainsi nous constatons tous les
jours que la réussite de tous les élèves
demande une réflexion approfondie des
professeurs sur leur pratique
pédagogique au regard d'un monde qui
change d'inégalité de plus en plus
importante et de l'ambition de permettre
à tous de maîtriser le socle commun de
connaissance de compéten et de
culture pour ce qui est de
l'interdisciplinarité et de la
pluridisciplinarité tout d'abord
l'interdisciplin plinarité elle
s'organise dans le cadre des EPI
permettant de construire et
d'approfondir des connaissances et des
compétences par une démarche de projet
conduisant à une réalisation concrète h
thématiques interdisciplinaires sont
ainsi prévues à ce jour les programmes
proposés à consultation par le CSP ne
déclinent pas de façon généralisée ces
thématiqu quelles problématiques
peuvent-elles recouvrir dans le cadre de
ces problématiques quel avir
disciplinaires peuvent être convoqués
notre organisation syndicale demande à
ce que les programmes avancent des
propositions dans ce sens afin de se
prémunir de la mise en œuvre de projets
aboutissant certes à des réalisations
concrètes mais sans de solides
apprentissages ainsi l'augmentation du
travail épistémologique des enseignants
risque de se faire au dépend de leur
réflexion didactique et
pédagogique deuxièmement la la
pluridisciplinarité
elle est aujour aujourd'hui au cœur de
l'accompagnement personnalisé mise en
œuvre au lycée et en 6e c'est ainsi que
plusieurs professeurs de différentes
disciplines contribuent à répondre aux
besoins des élèves à soutenir leur
capacité d'apprendre et de progresser à
améliorer leurs compétences et à
construire leur autonomie le choix
d'affecter cet horaire à l'horaire des
disciplines et non d'en faire un
enseignement en lien étroit mais
distinct des disciplines est à notre
sens un frein à ces collaborations
fécondes pour accompagner les élèves il
risque également de faire perdre de vue
l'identité pédagogique spécifique de cet
enseignement glissant vers un simple
complément
disciplinaire madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs c'est
au regard de ces réalités qui
impacteraient profondément les pratiques
pédagogiques évaluant progressivement de
façon favorable vers des apprentissages
de plus en plus solides et différenciés
que notre organisation syndicale demande
à ce que les discussions sur la réforme
du collège puisse reprendre pour aboutir
à des adaptations nécessaires nous vous
remercions pour votre attention merci
Monsieur Desf je donne la parole à notre
dernier invité qui vient de nous
rejoindre monsieur Paul devin pour le
Syndicat national des personnes de
l'inspection FSU vous avez la parole
monsieur quelques
instants madame la Présidente Mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
quelques éléments pour commencer sur
l'état du collège tout d'abord pour dire
qu'on ne peut pas le caractériser d'un
seul trait vouloir le résumer à l'ennui
des élèves à un carcan des disciplines
ou au désintérêt des professeurs à
vouloir y traiter les difficultés des
apprentissages trahirit l'effort
quotidien des équipes enseignantes qui
cherchent à transmettre des savoirs et
construire des compétences par un
exercice professionnel dont la
complexité est
croissante que le collège ne parviennent
pas à conduire tous ses élèves à la
réussite ne peut suffire à le désigner
comme le maillon faible du système
ce serait ignorer qu'il est confronté à
des problèmes spécifiques ceux de
l'adolescence et de ses comportements
contradictoires ceux de la disparité des
acquis dans la prise en compte est d'une
difficulté croissante au long de la
scolarité mais aussi ceux consécutifs à
une réduction progressive des moyens
dans un pays qui connaissait déjà des
taux d'encadrement moins favorables que
la moyenne des pays de
l'OCDE dans une période où le discours
général se plaît à répéter presque
exclusivement la faillite de l'école
certains seront étonnés qu'on puisse
évoquer la réussite du collège et
pourtant il faut la dire car le collège
c'est la réussite d'une volonté
politique essentielle celle de
scolariser ensemble toute une génération
d'adolescents et de développer pour eux
les mêmes
ambitions dire cela est nécessaire même
si par ailleurs il ne peut-être question
de nier que nous devons tourner nos
efforts vers la résolution du problème
majeur qui est celui de la
transformation des inégalités sociales
en inégalités
scolaire vous le savez nous ne
considérons pas que la réforme actuelle
puisse contribuer à lutter efficacement
contre les
inégalité cela ne résulte en rien d'un
conservatisme qui refuserait tout
changement n'agrégeons pas trop vite
tous les opposants à cette réforme les
raisons qui les guident ne sont pas les
mêmes nous défendons la mixité sociale
parce que nous la considérons comme une
nécessité pour le progrès de tous alors
que certains l'ont réduite en permettant
le renforcement de de la ségrégation par
la libération de la carte scolaire nous
voulons faire de la transmission des
savoirs le vecteur essentiel de
l'émancipation et de l'égalité alors que
d'autres en font une stratégie de
triociale la première nécessité de
réforme pour le collège c'est de réussir
à permettre une mixité sociale réelle
sur l'ensemble du territoire et pas
seulement en jouant à la marge par la
suppression de section d'autant que
certains établissements avaient
justement réussi à en faire un vecteur
de lutte contre la fuite de leurs
meilleurs élèves cette mixité demande
une politique déterminée volontaire et
courageuse elle est une urgence absolue
pour que dans certains territoires la
concentration des élèves les plus en
difficulté ne constitue pas une
situation sur laquelle les pédagogies
même les plus élaborées n'auront plus de
prise la seconde nécessité c'est celle
de donner au collège des moyens à la
hauteur de l'ambition que nous portons
pour tous ces élèves nous nous devons
nous réjouir que notre société ait
développé les attentes ambitieuses d'une
réussite de tous c'est le témoignage de
son attachement profond aux valeurs de
la démocratie mais lorsqu'on nourrit une
telle volonté il faut en assumer les
coûts les volontés de rationalisation
budgétaire ont été porté par un discours
de relativisation des moyens qui prétend
que la réalité n'aurait aucune relation
avec les moyens consacrés à l'action or
il est impossible de réformer par des
réorgan de surface essentiellement
préoccupé par la constance des coûts
peut-on décréter l'aide personnalisée
quand les moyens ne permettent pas le
dédoublement des classes peut-on vouloir
que soi mieux prise en compte les
difficultés des élèves sans interroger
la question des effectifs des classes
que l'on laisse fluctuer au gré des
variations démographiques peut-on
invoquer l'amélioration qualitative des
pédagogies mises en œuvre alors qu'on a
laissé faute de moyens la formation
continue se réduire d'année en année
peut-on développ la professionnalité des
enseignants alors que la baisse de leur
pouvoir d'achat et la dégradation de
leurs conditions de travail diminue
l'attirance pour leur métier et nous
confronte de manière de plus en plus
préoccupante vers la pénurie du
recrutement il ne sert à rien de
procéder à quelques aménagement en
faisant croire qu'il relèverait d'une
révolution pédagogique entendonsnous
bien la concertation des équipes est un
facteur nécessaire se préoccuper des
liens entre les disciplines est
essentiel car c'est dans sa globalité
que l'élève doit être capable
d'appréhender le monde pour développer
les compétences nécessaires à l'exercice
d'une citoyenneté libre et responsable
mais cela est d'abord et avant tout une
préoccupation des enseignements
disciplinaires et non la mise en œuvre
pratique d'un thème qui se construit sur
des liens très
superficiels cela nécessite d'identifier
des problématiques dont la résolution
fait appel à des concepts issu de
plusieurs champs disciplinaires
c'est-à-dire justement d'éviter la seule
liaison thématique superficielle dont on
peut douter qu'elle garantissent une
meilleure réussite des élèves cela
demande une élaboration complexe et la
formation des enseignants qui va avec
faute d'une volonté de consacrer à
l'enjeu majeur de l'éducation les moyens
dont il aurait besoin la réforme
s'appuie sur des volontés d'évolution
institutionnell dont on peut douter
qu'elles contribueront à de réelles
améliorations la première est
l'autonomie des établissements alors que
bien des pays de l'Europe du Nord nous
offrent les bilans désastreux de tels
choix le Royaume-Uni et la Suède pour ne
citer que ceux qui ont été l'objet de
publications les plus récentes certains
continuent à affirmer dogmatiquement que
l'autonomie des établissement
contribuera à la réussite des élèves
refusant de tirer parti de ces
expériences elle devrait pourtant nous
rendre très prudent sur le renforcement
des pouvoirs du chef d'établissement et
le recours aux méthodes
managériales parce que les organisations
nouvelles dont le décret demande la mise
en œuvre ne vont pas pouvoir procéder
d'une seule réflexion pédagogique des
équipes elles vont aussi devoir
conmer à des dotations horaires
disciplinaires qui parfois s'avont
incohérentes avec les projets quand bien
même ceci serit guidé par une évaluation
objective des besoins des élèves il
faudra trancher et cela sera sans doute
fait parfois sans ménagement penseon
qu'il résultera réellement une meilleure
coopération entre les
enseigns entre les enseignants la
réforme du collège pose avec une acé
particulière le problème de la réforme
du système éducatif notre société do
choisir si elle reste attachée à la
démocratisation de la réussite scolaire
si elle veut poursuivre ce formidable
effort qui depuis de longues années a
conduit à l'élévation du niveau de
formation et de qualification elle doit
en accepter les coûts nous ne
parviendrons pas à améliorer de manière
conséquente le service public
d'éducation sans un investissement à la
hauteur des enjeux sans questionner les
limites de d'une doxace de réduction
systématique des budgets de l'action
publique
oui nous voulons réformer le collège
c'est-à-dire que nous voulons contribuer
à rompre la détermination des liens qui
unissent les inégalités scolaires et les
inégalités sociales nous voulons que les
enfants des classes populaires dont nous
savons qu'aucune prédisposition
intellectuelle ne les confineent à une
réussite moindre puisse construire les
savoirs qui sont nécessaires à tous les
citoyens d'une société libre égalitaire
et fraternelle mais nous savons que cela
nécessite une politique qui ne peut se
content
d'affirmer des valeurs mais qui doit
conduire les choix budgétaires
nécessaires à défaut nous continuerons
ce qui devient désormais une activité
quasi rituelle eniler des réformes en
initier une nouvelle sur le constat
d'échec de la précédente et nous
constaterons à nouveau l'accentuation
des fractures sociales et toutes leurs
conséquences la pédagogie est
essentielle la qualité professionnelle
des enseignants est déterminante mais il
y a un point critique où elle risque
risque de n'être plus que côtaire sur
jambe de bois il ne s'agit pas de
brandir les menaces d'un déclin
irréversible mais d'alerter en fonction
de l'analyse que nous permet l'exercice
quotidien de nos métiers d'inspecteur et
nous pensons que c'est le devoir d'une
organisation syndicale que de le dire à
la représentation
nationale bien je vous remercie merci
Madame merci messieurs pour euh nous
avoir exposé le point de vue de vos
syndicats respectifs alors mes chers
collègues je vous propose que nous
procédions de la même manière que lors
de l'audition de madame la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale nous allons donner
la parole à notre rapporteur pour les
crédits de l'enseignement scolaire
monsieur jean-caud Carles pour 5 minutes
et après je vous propose d'avoir le la
même organisation permett à chacun de
pouvoir
s'exprimer dans le temps qui nous est
imparti voilà Monsieur Carles vous avez
la parole merci madame la Présidente je
vais essayer d'être moins long que lors
de l'audition de madame la ministre je
voudrais bien sûr à mon tour remercier
nos intervenants de de pour leur exposés
et j'aur un certain nombre de de
questions personne ne niit la nécessité
d'une réforme du collège tous les
acteurs que nous avons rencontrer même
si vous avez ils ont des appréciations
différentes des nuances certains même en
demandant même l'abrogation mais cette
réforme je crois tout le monde l'accepte
mais est-ce que c'est cette réforme qui
va permettre de régler le problème dont
vous avez parlé les uns et les autres he
qui est la liaison entre les inégalités
sociales et les inégalités scolaire dans
un pays où le déterminisme social est
fort et est-ce que la vraie réforme ça
n'est pas au début de l'acquisition des
fondamentaux c'est-à-dire du premier
cycle d'apprentissage des fondamentaux
hein le premier cycle de l'école
maternelle he car on sait très bien que
celui qui ne possède pas les qui ne
maîtrise pas les fondamentaux à l'entrée
au collège hein euh a des difficultés on
voit bien c'est la même proportion de
euh de de jeunes qui entrent au collège
et qui sortent du collège avec des
difficultés de maîtrise des fondamentaux
une récente enquête d'ailleurs de de de
l'éducation nationale montre que 20 %
des élèves qui sortent du collège ont
des difficultés en mathématiqu à
résoudre des euh problèmes qui sont euh
du niveau du euh CM2 est-ce que la vraie
réforme c'est pas celle justement de
l'acquisition rapide des euh
fondamentaux
ce j'en viiens maintenant si vous voulez
bien aux enseignements
interdisciplinaires dont chacun
reconnaît aussi la nécessité mais est-ce
que le fait qu'il soit pris sur le temps
des enseignements disciplinaires ne pose
pas là aussi un problème j'en viens à
l'étonomie des établissements à mon avis
cette réforme va dans le bon sens je
pense qu'elle ne va pas assez loin
j'avais fait un rapport en 2011 sur
l'autonomie des établissements en
faisant un certain nombre de proposition
sur l'évolution des missions des corps
d'inspection et vers l'évaluation des
établissements peut-être plus que
l'évaluation individuelle des
enseignants cette dernière me
semble-t-il devrait être du ressort ou
de la compétence du chef d'établissement
et j'avais proposé d'ailleurs une une
mesure pour essayer j'allais dire de
mettre de faire en sorte d'associer tous
les acteur de la communauté éducative
c'est de confier la présidence des ét à
une personnalité extérieure et que ça
soit pas uniquement le chef
d'établissement cette mesure existe
d'ailleurs dans l'enseignement agricole
qui après tout ne se porte pas si mal
sur la suppression des filières
d'excellence ou plutôt la remise en
cause des filières d'excellence alors
pourquoi là aussi supprimer ce qui
marche les classes bilang le latin et le
grec ou un certain nombre de disciplines
est-ce que là encore ça ne va pas
accroître inégalités en partant d'une
volonté tout à fait louable de vouloir
les euh diminuer et puis dernière
question sur l'orientation à la réforme
qui prévoit la suppression des options
de découverte professionnelle au profit
du parcours individuel d'information
d'orientation et découverte du monde
profession économique et professionnel
avec un sigle imprononçable les M
j'arrive jamais à le prononcer ce
parcours ne bénéficie d'aucune dotation
horaire spécifique et doit donc là aussi
être organisé sur le temps disciplinaire
de même que l'avenir des classes prépao
paraît également incertain un l'arrêté
mentionnant un complément de dotation
horaire spécifique sans en préciser le
volume ni la provenance et ça me semble
pas la meilleure manière de valoriser la
voie professionnelle à un moment où le
président de la République à juste titre
veut valoriser la voie professionnelle
que ce soit l'apprentissage ou par la la
voie scolaire et comment pourrait-on
mettre en place je dire une véritable
individualisation des parcours pour
faire en sorte qu'on passe aujourd'hui
de cette orientation subie ou cette
orientation par échec successif à une
orientation j'all dire plus
positive merci beaucoup monsieur le le
le rapporteur mes chers collègues je
vous propose de donner immédiatement la
parole aux représentants des des groupes
politiques dans leur re monsieur manier
madame mé et et Madame Blandin et je
redonnerai la parole à nos invités vous
aurez encore des questions par la suite
parce qu'il y a des orateurs qui sont
déjà inscrits voilà je vous demande de
bien noter les questions des uns et des
autres alors Monsieur manier vous avez
la parole pour merci madame la
Présidente à l'instar de mon collègue
Jean-Claude Carles je serai moi aussi
plus bref que je suis je l'étais la
dernière fois je m'en excuse encore une
fois 3 minutes j'ai beaucoup d'espoir
parce que Jean-Claude car vient de dire
la réforme va dans le bon sens nous
sommes en train de progresser c'est un
bon
signe en tout cas j'ai bien entendu ce
qu'on dit nos invités aussi bien les
représentants des chefs d'établissement
que des inspecteurs et je crois que
aujourd'hui il n'y a effectivement comme
ça a été dit pas de contestation sur
nécessité de réformer toutefois vouloir
réformer c'est une chose après quand on
veut réformer le collège et quand on
veut s'attaquer au programme quand on
veut essayer de donner aux élèves un peu
de d'espace et de respiration il faut
bien trouver des
matières sinon à supprimer au moins à
transforme dont on transforme le la
façon de les enseigner donc on ne peut
pas à mon avis à la fois adapter les
programmes réduire le temps de travail
des élèves comme c'est souhaitable et
nécessaire en collège garder tous les
contenus et et en même temps arriver à
satisfaire tout le monde donc je crois
qu'il faut faire des choix et à travers
cette réforme il y a effectivement des
choix qui sont fait et quand on critique
le fait de dire il n'y a plus de classe
bilang je dirais si il y a beaucoup plus
de classe bilang puisque à partir de la
5e on va faire deux langues étrangères
de langues vivantes donc on élargit on
élargit l'assiette puisque avant les
classes bilanges étaient réservé à
certains en 6e et généralisé en 4e
aujourd'hui elles le sont en 5e il y
aura bien de langues en 5e bien j'arrête
là-dessus puisque c'est un peu ma
défense de la de la de la réforme pour
pososer deux ou trois questions aux
chefs d'établissement qui sont là le
représentant des chefs d'établissements
les syndicats euh on entend parfois
certaines formation politique réclamer
que les chefs d'établissement recrutent
même les enseignants les professeurs on
l'a pas entendu ce matin hein je vous
rassure mais on l'entend parfois qu'en
pensez-vous euh ça a été abordé je crois
par l'un ou l'autre d'entre vous la
liaison cours moyen 6e avec ce cycle 3
aujourd'hui qui refond la liaison qu'en
pensez-vous euh et puis c'est tout voilà
en tout cas j'arrêter là merci merci de
votre concision monsieur manier madame
Méo pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la
Présidente je
voudrais dire tout d'abord que la
réforme est nécessaire hein nous je
crois que nous pouvons être d'accord sur
ce point notre collège doit évoluer mais
bon le collège unique et révolue je
crois que nous sommes plus ou moins
d'accord là-dessus que l'autonomie est
indispensable pour donner plus de marge
de manœuvre au chefs d'établissement
selon la population scolaire reçue et
selon les
besoins mais il faut
proposer en plus du socle commun
indispensable pour que les élèves
puissent acquérir les fondamentaux une
diversification d'options afin que
les élèves
puissent selon leurs aptitudes et leur
goût trouver un
épanouissement au cours de leur
scolarité il faut aussi mettre l'accent
sur l'aide personnalisée et avoir les
moyens de le faire
réellement et à ce stade je voudrais
insister aussi sur la pertinence des
classes bilangues et des classes
européennes
euh c'est voix ont
montré leur efficacité et euh ce n'était
pas surtout pour des enfants dit
favorisés euh dans des établissements
difficiles en zone d'éducation
prioritaire ces ces voix ont montré leur
leur grande
efficacité et euh je souhaite
euh insister sur l'importance de
l'enseignement de l'allemand et rappeler
qu'il y a eu un un engagement au plus
haut niveau euh lors du 50e anniversaire
du traité de l'Élysée euh de part et
d'autrees l'engagement de nos gouvernant
était de favoriser la langue du
Partenaire Européen ceci mérite
réflexion il pourrait être opportun de
présenter l'Allemagne qui est donc notre
partenaire euh privilégié en Europe et
la langue allemande à tous les élèves
comme il est question de de présenter la
culture latine et grecque euh puisqu'il
s'agit de de des origines de de notre
culture voilà c'était ce point que je
voulais faire merci merci d'être resté
dans le le temps imparti madame Blandin
pour le groupe écologiste vous avez la
parole merci madame la
Présidente merci de à toutes les
personnes qui se sont sont exprimé et
les écologistes retiennent des temps
forts comme les demandes de
formationuees les demande de temps
interne à l'établissement pour les
équipes pédagogiques et une grande place
au conseil pédagogique tout cela ira
dans le bon sens euh dans cet esprit
est-ce que les chefs d'établissement
vont prévoir un temps de lecture commune
du socle commun à la rentrée pour une
appropriation par tous les enseignant
et dans l'élaboration de leurs emplois
du temps vont-ils pouvoir laisser une
place plus grande à l'identification des
équipes pédagogiques car celles-ci
auront effectivement un rôle accru en
particulier pour les épis ensuite nous
voudrions connaître vos aspirations sur
le phasage de la mise en œuvre de cette
réforme et enfin par rapport aux
inspections est-ce que les corps
d'inspection en particulier
disciplinaire d'ailleurs prévoi des
évolutions de leur pratique pour
faciliter l'accompagnement des
enseignants dans les mutations prévu par
la loi les programmes et la
réforme merci Madame blanda madame
Laborde pour le groupe
RDSE merci madame la Présidente ce sera
très bref parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites je crois que nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire que la réforme
est nécessaire et au cours d'un certain
nombre de table rondes nous avons vu
quand même qu'il y a toujours des avis
divergents mais c'est ce qui fait
avancer les choses et moi mon propos
rejoint un petit peu ce que vient de
dire Madame Blandin puisque ce qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est la formation
des enseignants pour être prêt en
septembre 2016 donc est-ce que voilà ça
rejoint la question sur le phasage tout
à fait donc c'est ça qui est je pense
très important et une question que
j'avais posé à madame la ministre qui
n'a pas été tout à fait clair dans sa
réponse où je l'ai pas comprise euh
n'est-ce pas occasion aussi de réformer
le brevet des collèges ou voir le
supprimer je vous laisse la réponse
merci merci Madame labord monsieur abat
pour le groupe CRC
oui on va pas revenir effectivement à
chaque fois sur le fond du sujet chacun
s'est largement exprimé je crois que les
valeurs qui sont affirmées dans cette
réforme sont des valeurs qui sont nobles
c'est clair et après bien sûr se pose le
problème des en tout cas c'est ma vision
des choses et et après se pose le
problème de la mise en moi j'ai juste
une question très très concrète
puisqu'on a et on les remercie à faire à
des responsables direction chef
d'établissement et inspecteur est-ce que
et sans évoquer le problème des moyens
qu' déjà été évoqué moyens pour la
formation est-ce que un moyen égal ou
avec les moyens affichés qui sont quand
même supplémentaires par rapport aux
politiques précédentes en tout cas c'est
l'engagement est-ce que dans ces
moyenslà on peut imaginer que
concrètement dans un collège euh
du fait de l'autonomie de la
pluridisciplinarité des de l'aide de
l'aide personnalisée est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que concrètement il puisse y
avoir des classes je vais faire un
peut-êre une bêtise ou faire un peu de
provoque mais des classe de 10 12 gamins
quand vraiment on en a besoin pour
vraiment leur donner du temps et puis
des classes je vais faire la provoque de
nouveau de 40 gamins quand ils ont tous
chez eux à la maison le voilà je fais
c'est la concrètement et puis et de la
même manière est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
que dans un même bassin d'emploi de vie
dans une même région euh où souvent on a
pas si loin que ça des collèges entre
guillemets favorisés et puis des
collèges entre guillemets défavorisés ou
en tout cas des collèges où la réussite
elle est plus compliquée en terme de
cohésion et en terme de d'accès au socle
commun est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
qu'il y ait dans dans un collège pour un
certain temps parce qu'il va être
difficile de faire déménager les parents
faut pas non plus raconter de bêtises he
forcer les parents à enlever les gamins
d'un collège pour les mettre ailleurs
mais Don dans un collège imaginez qu'on
puisse avoir des classes de nouveau de
10 12 élèves puis dans l'autre où c'est
c'est plus facile des classes de 30 35
élèves parce que le vrai problème en
fait c'est le temps qu'on donne à un
élève pour
apprendre et là il a pas le temps il est
vite sanctionné s'il est pas dans le
rythme s'il court pas au M que la
moyenne il est sanctionné et puis le
vrai problème c'est le le le nombre
d'élèves par classe moi je crois que si
on
pouvait organiser les choses de telle
sorte que là il y ait effectivement de
la souplesse on pourrait peut-être
améliorer concrètement mais c'est
effectivement un problème de moyen c'est
clair merci Monsieur abat notre
rapporteur et l'ensemble des groupes
politiques ou presesse se sont exprimés
donc je vais revenir vers nos invités
pour qu'ils puissent répondre aux
nombreuses questions qui ont été posées
des questions assez précises sachant que
Madame Lopez monsieur groserin Monsieur
assouine Madame duchen madame Cartron
madame Blondin et Monsieur sain
prendront ensuite la la parole alors je
ne sais pas qui souhaite s'exprimer
parmi vous Monsieur l'Inspecteur ou
souhaitez je vous vois prêt à appuyer
sur le micro donc alors écoutez je vais
je vais commencer donc sur le la
question des de la formation des
enseignants de l'accompagnement de la
réforme par les inspecteurs
euh clairement donc nos recteurs nous
ont déjà réunis ont réunit selon les
académies les chefs d'établissement un
calendrier quasiment déjà établis selon
les académies euh les formations seront
d'abord par district un district c'est
parfois une trentaine d'établissements
que malgré tout euh ensuite des
formations prévoient de s'adresser aux
professeurs représentant du conseil
pédagogique donc là nous serions sur le
mois de janvier février et puis enfin
euh dernier trimestre de l'année il est
prévu des formations sur les nouveaux
programmes et la mise en place donc de
la réforme pour la rentrée 2016 pour
l'ensemble des professeurs donc
j'insiste encore sur le fait que les les
IAPR he quel que soit leur
positionnement aujourd'hui exprimé par
rapport à ces réformes seront au premier
plan pour les pour l'accompagner cette
réforme quand le temps de la discussion
sera terminé il est évident que
l'engagement des IPR sera sans faille
alors je ne sais pas si j'ai répondu à
une petite partie de la question la
totalité mais sur la formation voilà un
petit peu comment les choses se
présentent bien madame oui je vais je
vais essayer alors pas de répondre sur
toutes les questions mais sur un certain
nombre de questions qui nous qui nous
interrogent par rapport à notre
positionnement du SAN CFD euh euh une
question a été posée sur l'évaluation
des personnels l'évaluation des
établissements l'autonomie des
établissements euh AUG CFDT nous sommes
pour une évolution forte de l'évaluation
des personnels et de passer sur des
évaluations beaucoup plus sur une
beaucoup plus de collectif c'est bien
les équipes et le fonctionnement des
équipes qui est à qui est à évaluer et
euh nous avons déjà participé à des
groupes de travail sur l'évaluation des
personnels et je crois que le ministère
dans le cadre des groupes chantiers des
métiers doit ouvrir ça fait partie des
groupes transversaux qui devaient
s'ouvrir la réflexion sur l'évaluation
des personnels nous nous sommes prêts à
non pas faire évaluer les personnel par
les chefs d'établissement qui n'ont pas
la compétence pédagogique même si sur
l'investissement dans l'établissement il
peut certainement y avoir une réflexion
sur sur leur rôle dans dans cette
évaluation vous avez fait quelqu'un
d'autre a fait une une proposition sur
la la la présidence des conseills
d'administration je ne vous cacherai pas
qu'au g CFDT nous avons comme position
que nous souhaiterions que le chef
établissement ne soit plus le président
du conseil d'administration tout
simplement parce qu'on est dans une
situation de diichotomie terrible voire
de schizophrénie quand effectivement en
tant qu'exécutif de l'établissement euh
on est aussi le représentant de l'État
et il nous semble qu'à un moment où on
donne de l'autonomie au aux
établissements et aux équipes
d'établissement euh le le le fait que le
chef d'établissement soit aussi
l'exécutif de l'établissement rend
souvent cette impression conforte cette
impression que le ca devient une chambre
enregistrement là je réponds très
clairement euh on serait pas forcément
pour une pour que ce soit une
personnalité extérieure il y a d'autres
d'autres d'autres proposition que l'on
peut faire mais c'est vrai que sur le ca
c'est une proposition que nous portons
depuis longtemps euh en ce qui concerne
les filières d'excellence supprimer ce
qui marche moi je dirais quand même que
si on est dans on est bien dans le cadre
d'une réorientation des moyens
aujourd'hui je prendrai un exemple dans
une le fonctionnement d'une classe
bilangue de du latin pour euh pour le 5e
4e 3e correspond à la dotation dans un
collège moyen de tout ce qui permet de
faire de l'aide personnalisée aux élèves
de 6e si on a cinq classes de 6e ça ça
fait effectivement avec 30 élèves par
classe ça fait beaucoup d'élèves et au G
CFDT si la question qui nous a été posée
par le ministère c'est si on réoriente
les moyens où sont les priorités nous
notre priorité elle est bien sur les
élèves qui ont le plus besoin des
horaires supplémentaires et la loi
définit bien que le que le que les
horaires qui sont à donn pour l'ensemble
des élèves soi identiques ce qui
condamne quelque part le système des
options je vous remercie monsieur
Richard oui quelques réponses nous
sommes favorables à une réforme en
profondeur du diplôme national du brevet
pour lui donner de la cohérence soit
nous sommes dans la logique de la
validation du socle commun de
connaissance de compétenence et de
culture et donc bien évidemment dans ce
cas c'est cette validation qui marquera
la fin de de l'enseignement au collège
et donc le maintien d'un d'un examen
terminal qui s'est qui n'a cessé de se
complexifier avec à la fois du contrôle
en cours de formation du contrôle
continu des épreuves terminales des
épreuves spécifiques ne fait que
surcharger et perturber les enseignement
en ce qui concerne la mise en œuvre de
la réforme les textes ont été publiés
donc à la rentrée de septembre nous
aurons une année complète une année
civile une année scolaire devant nous
pour travailler au sein des
établissements dans les conseils
d'enseignement dans les conseils
pédagogiques au conseil d'administration
pour travailler à la préparation de la
rentrée 2016 et d'intégrer dans la
préparation de cette rentrée les
modalités de la réforme nous pensons
nous que les enseignants doivent être
valorisés dans le rôle de fonctionnaire
de catégorie A c'est-à-dire de cadres
qui sont donc capables de réfléchir
d'analyser de synthétiser et d'avoir des
modalités euh de réflexion qui débouche
sur un projet d'établissement qui
correspond le mieux aux besoins des
élèves et puis sur le dernier point
c'est la présidence des conseils
d'administration nous avons au snpdn une
position différente de celle de ma
collègue nous pensons que il est
indispensable que le chef
d'établissement continue de présider le
conseil d'administration pour deux
raisons j'interroge ici les élus que
vous êtes est-ce que l' envisage un seul
instant que le maire ne préside plus son
conseil municipal c'est une à mon avis
il y a peu de réponse favorbl et donc il
semble indispensable que le représentant
de l'État soit celui qui préside le
conseil d'administration comme c'est le
cas dans tous les établissements publics
il n'y a pas que les ople qui sont des
établissements publics tous les
établissements publics voir leur conseil
d'administration présidé par le
représentant de l'État c'est une
garantie pour le fonctionnement de ces
de ce conseil d'administration nous en
avons fait la prve depuis maintenant 30
ans puisque c'est depuis le décret du 30
août 85 donc plus de 40 ans après nous
avons fait la preuve que ce dispositif
fonctionne et qu'il garantit une
certaine pérénité et sérénité des débats
tout autre présidence ne manquerait pas
d'avoir des entraîner des difficultés
quant à l'excellence et ben bien
évidemment que c'est une nécessité pour
un service public d'éducation que de la
promouvoir mais nous pensons que système
éducatif moderne et démocratique doit
avoir comme priorité la bienveillance
c'est-à-dire d'être en permanence dans
une volonté de d'accueillir et de faire
réussir les élèves et donc pour nous la
bienveillance va de paire avec
l'exigence parce que la bienveillance
sans exigence ça porte un nom ça
s'appelle la
démagogie merci sur la présidence du du
conseil d'administration je me tourne
vers 3è représentant des personnels de
direction monsieur lafac vous souhaitez
vous exprimer oui s'il vous plaît bien
j'avais deux ou trois points sur sur
lequel effectivement je souhaitais je
souhaitais m'exprimer alors sur la la
présidence des conseils d'administration
on ne peut pasier que chez nous le débat
existe c'est une
évidence majoritairement nos collègues
pensent que l'unicité du fonctionnement
de l'établissement exige au moins
pendant quelques temps encore la
présidence par du conseiladministration
par chef d'établissement et la relation
avec les établissements agricoles qui
nous Inter
aussi puisque effectivement sont des
collègues avec lesquels nous
travaillons nous semble être un petit
peu faussé parce que généralement le
représentant enfin le président du
conseil d'administration des
établissements agricoes est quelqu'un
qui est très impliqué dans le monde de
l'agriculture et qui donc a une vision
et une
connaissance du du système donc pour
l'instant nous cherchons la personnalité
dans le système actuel tant qu'il tant
qu'il Estel tel qu'il est qui
pourrait représenter l'établissement et
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas trouvé
le d'identification de d'un personnage
pertinent dans ce domaine on n'imagine
pas un parent d'élèves on Nimagine pas
ENF et cetera enfin pour l'instant on n
pas de solution qui nous semble plus
favorable que celle du maintien de la
présidence même si je vous dis la
question fait Desbat parce que
effectivement nous sommes souvent entre
deux logiques celle du représentant de
l'État et celle du représentant de de
notre établissement néanmoins
pour le fonctionnement d'établissement
aujourd'hui notre syndicat reste
favorable au maintien pour le chef
d'établissement président du conseil
d'administration sur le recrutement des
des professeurs par les personnels de
direction pour nous la question ne se
est un refus absolu tout simplement
parce que ce serait et on connaît bien
le système par exemple britannique ce
serait créer une concurrence
qui amènerait sans aucun doute des
établissements plus prestigieux des
établissement mieux situés et cetera à
être tellement talléchant que on verrait
les les
enseignant organiser une carrière sur
des intérêts je dire personnels bien
plus importants qu'aujourd'hui ou malgré
tout le système compense même s'il est
loin d'être parfait mais l'état veille
quand même à une répartition des des des
personnels il regardez la question des
assistants d'éducation les assistants
d'éducation alors je suis principal de
collège depuis plus de 25 ans je suis
toujours principal de collège et les
assistants d'éducation dans les communes
proches des universités sont des
étudiants dans les communes rurales les
assistants d'éducation au collège ce
sont alors je n'ai rien contre mais ça
change complètement le fonctionnement ce
sont des mares de famille ce sont des
des gens qui j'allais dire sont en
reconversion d'une manière ou d'une
autre et on n' pas du tout mais
absolument pas les mêmes équipes les
mêmes les mêmes projets les mêmes
manières de les piloter donc on aurait
nous le redoutons des des des
problématiques du même type la formation
des enseignants pour la réforme elle est
nécessaire et le phasage qu'on nous
propose qui se termine au mois de
j'allais dire au mois de juin nous
semble particulièrement délicat puisque
chacun sait que la préparation d'une
rentrée ne se fait pas au mois de juin
où on a d'ailleurs bien d'autres choses
à penser et cette année encore plus que
jamais mais elle se fait en
janvier-février lors de la répartition
des moyens attribués et des projets liés
aux personnes lié au lié au postes donc
le fait
de devoir
entre la rentrée de septembre intégrer
les nouveau programmes alors la lecture
commune peut-être une méthode je ne sais
pas si c'est celle que nous retiendrons
dans les établissements où il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup d'enseignants mais
les enseignants je vous l'assure
s'intéressent à ces au au nouveau socle
les discussions vont bon train sur le
sujet donc je ne suis pas trop inquiet
dans ce domaine mais il est clair que la
l'appropriation et la la la création de
montage de projets avec des équipes à la
fois disciplinaires et
interdisciplinaires tout ça avant le
mois de janvier va quand même rendre la
vie des établissements scolaires de que
sont les collèges un petit peu compliqué
c'est un 12 euphémisme
euh encore un point un point intéressant
qui a été abordé c'est le point des
effectifs et là c'est un point qui qui
j'allais dire préoccupe effectivement
l'idée est alléchante et elle se trouve
confrontée à différents problèmes
notamment et j'allais dire très très
matériellement au problèmes de salle on
sait que lorsqueon est on a supprimé les
dédoublements en technologie on s'est
rendu compte que les classes avaient été
construites par les les salles de classe
avaient été construit par les
collectivités locales pour accueillir
des groupes de moins de 20 élèves quand
on s'est quand on nous a dit il faut en
accepter 28 ça a été complexe alors il
faut bien penser que derrière chaque
modification même aussi banale on a des
problème matériels qui se pose de qu'il
ne faut pas négliger et qui pour les
gens de terrain que nous sommes sont des
problèmes qui sont de vrais soucis voilà
bien cette dernière remarque intéresse
particulièrement nos collègues qui
siègent dans les conseils départementaux
bien sûr madame paayat je vous ai
interrompu tout à l'heure je pensais que
vous aviez terminé donc je vous redonne
la parole surres questions puis après
monsieur devin demander la j'avais juste
un de points autour du brevet mais je
reviendrai pas sur ce que mon collègue
nous partageons tout à fait l'avis sur
le brevet des collèges et sur la et sur
la euh cet examen baroque qui qui qui
est enfin qu'on peut avoir ou pas avoir
ça change rien le le le collège c'est la
la validation du socle et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut trancher et et nous
ne sommes pas favorables à un maintien
du brevet c'est un point qu'on a abordé
avec le ministère euh sur le je voulais
revenir sur le recrutement des des des
des professeurs par le par le chef
d'établissement nous n'y sommes pas
favorables du tout par contre nous
sommes en train de réfléchir à des
propositions où on mixerait dans les
dans les dans les mutations des
personnels à la fois le le choix le
choix géographique et la capacité aussi
à se positionné par rapport par rapport
à des projets d'établissement parce
qu'il nous semble que si on souhaite que
les que les que les collègues
s'investissent aussi c'est aussi par
rapport à des à des choix à des choix de
parcours à des parcours de formation si
effectivement il y a parcours de
formation un peu spécifique ça peut
intéresser peut-être aussi les collègues
dans leur demande de mutation euh nous
pensons aussi qu'en ce qui concerne le
le la réforme du collège il serait
cohérent de réfléchir sur la les
conséquences d'un travail par cycle pour
les personnels c'estàd que nous avons
des cycles qui durent 3 ans si des
collègues sont investis dans des dans
des projet je pense en particulier à
tous ceux qui sont soit en complément de
service sur des établissements soit
titulaires sur zon de remplacement que
l'on puisse dans ce cas avoir des
maintiens des personnels pendant la
durée du projet sur 3 ans ça c'est
quelque chose chose que nous sommes en
train de réfléchir aussi au niveau de de
l'établissement et qui a des
conséquences sur sur le sur le mouvement
des personnels il faudra que le
ministère et que dans les académies on
en tienne compte dans les dans dans les
dans dans dans les capas pour la
formation nous partageons l'inquiétude
enfin ce que disait mon collègue sur le
fait que si on commence à à préparer la
rentrée simplement l'année prochaine au
mois de au 3è trimestre ce sera un petit
peu tard nous nous avons demandé
officiellement à la ministre que pendant
les deux premières années cette année de
construction et l'année prochaine
on puisse en finir avec le schéma d'une
fin d'année après le brevet ou dans les
établissements quand même bah je veux
dire on on a quand même les élèves il y
a plus véritablement de cours efficaces
il nous semble que pour cette
préparation de 2 années nous nous avons
demander à ce qu'il y ait la possibilité
d'autoriser les équipes à déjà se réunir
pour lire la le texte le texte des
décrets des arrêtés pour qu'ils en pour
que tout le monde en le le découvre
vraiment parce que ce qui a circulé dans
la presse dans les médias
a quand même mis beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de d'incompréhension voire de
contrevérité il nous semble fondamental
que ce soit maintenant qu'on puisse y
travailler dans les établissements
scolaires nous avons demandé
officiellement cette banalisation
postbrevet et qu'on la reconduise aussi
l'année prochaine mais qu'on puisse
effectivement faire de la formation sur
site dans les établissements dès le
premier trimestre des temps de travail
pour préparer effectivement la la le le
la préparation de rentrée en janvier
sinon on ne s'en sortira pas d'AC merci
madame monsieur devin vous avez la
parole l'une d'entre vous a dit tout à
l'heure le collège unique est révolu ben
j'espère que non enfin j'espère que nous
continuons quand même quels que soi les
choix de réforme qui seront fait à
penser le collège comme un lieu où on
scolarise ensemble toute une génération
d'élèves avec la même ambition pour tous
j'ose espérer que ce sera la ligne
directrice de toutes les réformes qui
seront engagées quel quelle qu'en soit
la nature sur la question du recrutement
par les chefs
d'établissement j'ai travaillé longtemps
en sc
saint je sais ce que produirait une
telle une telle modification des
procédures de
recrutement la SC s devrait se contenter
à ce moment-là d'une majorité
d'enseignants qui seraient des
contractuels non formés parce que on
connaît évidemment je dirais les
mécanismes naturels de ce que seront les
déplacements d'enseignants
voilà alors si effectivement on on
accepte de prendre le risque que les
territoires qui sont déjà socialement
les plus fragile doivent en plus
encaisser si je peux dire ce que seront
l'ensemble des conséquences d'un tel
recrutement je je suis persuadé que
enfin je pense pas qu'on puisse rêver
que ça apporte quoi que ce soit en
matière d'AM d'amélioration de la
démocratisation de la réussite des
élèves je pense même que ça serait
quelque chose d'extrêmement grave dans
les dans la conséquence que ça aurait
sur la sur la présidence du conseil
d'administration je rejoins totalement
ce qu'a dit Monsieur Richard tout à
l'heure c'est le représentant de l'État
qui doit qui doit présider le conseil
d'administration c'est une logique là
aussi on prendrait des risques à
fragiliser cette logique et puis je
terminerai sur la question de la
formation vous allez peut-être penser
que c'est chez moi un discours qui vire
à l'obsessionnel mais parler de la
formation c'est parler des moyens enfin
je ne vois pas comment nous qui sommes
régulièrement confrontés à la question
de comment on organise des formations
comment très concrètement on permet à
des enseignants de pouvoir bénéficier de
formation d'accompagnement la question
qui se pose d'abord et avant tout c'est
de combien de moyens disposons-nous pour
pouvoir organiser ces formations parce
qu'une formation ça coûte parce que ça
demande de libérer du temps enseignant
pour que ces enseignants puissent être
en formation à ce moment-là donc on ne
peut pas à la fois dire ce qui me semble
être quelque chose d'incontournable
c'est-à-dire que la question de la
construction de la liaison entre l'école
élémentaire et le
collège ça demande de la formation ça ne
viendra pas tout seul ça demande un
accompagnement fort des des enseignants
je vais pas faire la liste toutes les
autres questions que nous avons abordé
ici aujourd'hui demande une formation
importante
or tous les indicateurs dans ce domaine
sont extrêmement négatif la formation
continue a fortement diminué et dans
beaucoup d'endroits aujourd'hui elle est
pas loin de ne plus exister donc je je
le redis on ne peut pas à la fois
affirmer l'importance et la nécessité de
la formation continue sans s'intéresser
à la question des moyens qui doivent
être attribués pour permettre sa mise en
œuvre bien je vous remercie est-ce qu'un
autre d'entre vous souhaite s'exprimer
monsieur omaniaac allez-y oui oui pour
dire d'abord que j'étais impressionné de
pas voir le en voyant le le beau
consensus autour d'une idée simple il
faut
réformer personne n'a dit qu'il ne
fallait surtout pas réformer le collège
et c'est plutôt intéressant sauf que en
même temps on peut se demander est-ce
que ça suffira parce que le gros
problème c'est que les forme on en a
connu on en connaîtra probablement
d'autres mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut
réformer réellement et là les avis
commencent à diverger on commence par
enlever un petit bout de ceci ou par
retoucher un petit peu cela mais en même
temps est-ce qu'on n'oublie pas une
seule question importante est-ce que
tout de l'éducation des élèves se passe
au niveau du système éducatif et est-ce
que en réformant le système
éducatif dans interne on sera vraiment
capable de faire évoluer les choses
depuis maintenant une trentaine
quarantaine d'années les chercheur en
sciences sociales nous montrre à quel
point il est illusoire de penser que les
compétences et les connaissances d'un
individu se construisent exclusivement
dans des lieux destinés étiquetés pour
cela c'est-à-dire l'école parce que bien
évidemment on apprend des tas de choses
en dehors de l'école et peut-être
faudrait-il se dire que l'école la
première des réformes c'est d'imaginer
comment est-ce qu'on peut aider les
élèves à construire et extraire des
connaissances par rapport à cette masse
d'information dont il dispose
aujourd'hui masse d'information parfois
extrêmement contradictoire extrêmement
dangereus on connaît tous les problèmes
que peuvent entraîner certaines
informations sur l'Internet pour des
esprits faibles et malalléables à un
moment donné de leur histoire et on sait
tous à quel point il serait fondamental
d'aider tous les les jeunes à mieux
comprendre tous ces enjeux de
l'information qui est partout donc c'est
peut-être le cœur de la réforme et
peut-être se dire que la réforme ce
n'est pas une réforme de spécialiste
c'est une réforme de société qui doit
être mise en place et si on veut mettre
en place une réforme de société sans
doute faut-il oser des choses
radicalement différentes sans doute
faut-il oser accepter l'idée que
l'éducation n'est pas l'affaire
exclusive des spécialistes de
l'éducation que sont les enseignants ou
les cadres du système système éducatif
ou le ministère de l'Éducation nationale
mais que ça concerne la totalité des
citoyens ce qui veut dire par exemple
que si on imagine à l'heure actuelle des
territoires apprenants quand on dit le
mot territoire probablement faut-il
penser aussi associer les acteurs
majeurs des territoires que sont les
élus c'est-à-dire se lancer dans quelque
chose qui soit de l'ordre d'une
coconstruction des politiques éducatives
à l'échelle de territoire pour essayer
de développer des synergies et d'arrêter
de penser que tout incombe à l'école en
terme de responsabilité de la réussite
des jeunes et en terme d'échec dans la
réussite des jeunes on est tous
concernés et il faut vraiment qu'on se
lance résolument dans des solutions de
cet ordre qui existent déjà on n'est pas
dans quelque chose je n'évoque pas ici
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre d'une
utopie j'évoque quelque chose qui existe
dans de multiples territoires qu'on
connaît peu qu'on fait peu émerger et
qui pourutant mériterait d'être mis en
exerg pour qu'on voit ce qu'on peut
construire quand on travaille ensemble
au lieu de travailler chacun à son
niveau je pense qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on évolue considérablement et qu'on a
possibilité de le faire qu'on arrête
d'être dans un dogmatisme absolu disant
que l'école doit l'école bien sûr
qu'elle doit et les cadres bien sûr
qu'ils vont accompagner la réforme mais
si cette réforme est simple ement une
réforme de structure elle n'a aucune
chance d'aboutir elle n'aboutira que si
on en fait une réforme systémique qui
concerne tous les niveaux la liaison
entre le 1ier et le second degré est un
exemple mais la liaison entre le collège
et le lycée la logique du bac- 3 bac + 3
on n'arrête plus sa scolarité à la fin
du lycée c'est terminé c'est illusoire
ou alors le lycée n'est plus exactement
le lycée que nous connaissions autrefois
et il devient un continuum avec les
enseignant les enseignements postback
tout ça il faut l'oser mais tout ça il
faut le construire ensemble dans une
véritable synergie et non pas dans un
isolement de l'éducation
nationale bien monsieur rouagnac je vous
remercie mes chers collègues je dois
aller conclure un colloque au nom de
notre commission donc je vais laisser la
présidence à notre collègue Jean-Claude
Carles pour terminer cette cette séance
et je remercie nos invités je les pris
de de
m'excuser
d'accord merci la parole est donc à
Madame
Lopez lui demandant là aussi de pas
excéder 2 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames madames Messieurs mes
chers collègues alors moi je voudrais
dire je rejoins un petit peu le propos
de Monsieur devin qui disait tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas que le collège le
maillon faible de l'enseignement cela
d'ailleurs rejoint les propos de
Monsieur rouagnac qu' vient de tenir
ainsi que Monsieur Jean-Claude Carles
qui disait que l'entrée au collège il
fallait maîtriser les fondamentaux donc
ne croyez-vous pas que le fait de ne
plus vouloir de redoublement pour ne pas
heurter soi-disant les enfants ou plutôt
toucher l'ég des parents n'est pas un
peu une erreur parce que je pense que le
redoublement n'est pas une punition mais
au contraire donner une deuxième chance
à des enfants qui ont eu plus de
difficultés je crois parfois soit pour
des problèmes de santé soit pour des
problèmes familiaux
ou comme disais je crois tout à l'heure
quelqu'un certains enfants mettent plus
de temps pour apprendre moi je crois
qu'un enfant qui arrive en 6e et qui ne
maîtrise pas tout et bien il se
décourage petit à petit il s'enfonce
donc moi je pense que le doublement en
primaire et peut-être une nécessité
comme il peut être nécessaire aussi au
collège un enfant qui par contre avance
et puis qui s'ennuie en classe au bout
d'un moment se décourage ça c'est la
première question sur le redoublement
quant aux langues je pense que on a pu
constater que des enfants nés de parents
de nationalités différentes qui leur
parlent plusieurs langues les enfants
maîtrise parfaitement d'ailleurs on se
rend compte que certains établissements
frontaliers un jour de classe en
français un jour de classe dans une
autre langue les enfants arrivent en 6e
à maîtrisant parfaitement donc les deux
langues pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne
généraliserait pas donc l'apprentissage
d'une langue dès la maternelle avec un
jour de classe en français un jour de
classe dans une autre langue ça
prendrait peut-être un peu plus de temps
mais peut-être que ce serait la façon
pour arriver en 6e et maîtriser de langu
je vous
remercie merci président merci à T tous
les tous les représentants syndcoo
d'avoir accepté ce cet exercice mais moi
je m'interroge quand même si vous n'êtes
pas resté dans un discours qui est dû à
votre fonction et je le comprends et je
l'entends mais à vous entendre le
collège unique est formidable quoi donc
moi j'ai l'impression quand même que le
collège unique a a vécu on arrive
actuellement dans un système où où il y
a plus 700 élèves qui quittent le
collège alors je comprends pas à vous
entendre je pense qu'à moment donné il
faut il faut peut-être qu'on sorte les
uns et les autres peut-être moi-même
aussi d'un certain un dogmatisme ou
idéologie parce que il a véritablement
des des grandes difficultés par rapport
à ça vous parlez de formation continue
bah supprimer le DNB hein c'est 45
d'euros les choses seront faites je
pense que ça peut être intéressant je
suis surpris de ne pas vous avoir
entendu sur ce décret qui a été qui est
sorti le lendemain de de certains types
de manifestations en tout cas je parle
pour les représentations syndicales je
pense qu'il y avait quelque chose à
faire vis-à-vis de cela mais est-ce que
ça traduit pas cette réforme du collège
plutôt une idéologie dans la suppression
des langues bon on l'a bien vu hein même
si certains disent qu'on va le répartir
chez les autres je suis pas sûr que ça
marchera véritablement comme ça est-ce
que ça on parlait aussi à un moment
donné suppression des notes on parle de
de différents types de programmes on va
pas tout mélanger mais est-ce que ça
traduit pas certainement un certain type
d'idéologie de bienveillance comme vous
dites souvent à savoir bah voilà on va
faire en sorte que tous les élèves
réussissent mais à faire à force de
faire cela on va tuer le collège encore
plus de manière plus forte parce que les
élèves les meilleurs ou les plus
ambitieux ou les plus travailleurs ceux
qui envie de réussir les parents
permettaient cette mixité sociale à les
envoyer dans des endroits difficiles
parce qu'il avait justement cette
spécificité là on va encore getiser
encore plus les collèges parce que les
élèves partiront et on le sait on a
entendu les représentants de
l'enseignement privé le dire ils seront
capables de mettre en place ces
situations alternatives donc juste des
questions un est-ce que ça va pas
fragiliser encore plus ce collège unique
qu'il faudrait rendre à mon avis
beaucoup plus souple parce que si on
narrive pas à le rendre plus souple
c'est petit LCÉE qui existe n'est pas
quelque chose d'intéressant donc il faut
à mon avis réfléchir par rapport à cela
et puis je n'ai pas parlé de vie
scolaire de notre de vie scolaire on
pourrait s'interroger sur la note de vie
scolaire on pourrait s'interroger sur le
fait que quand j'entends le représentant
des syndical syndical des des
chefsétablissement qui nous dit on peut
pas noter les les profs qui mieux que
les que les chefsétablissement
connaissent le travail des profs qui
mieux que les chefsétablissement peuvent
dire quels sont les bons profs ou les
mauvais profs je crois qu'un moment
donné on peut s'interroger par rapport à
ça aussi puis enfin derni dernière
question s'il y avait une modification à
apporter à cette réforme du collège
quelle pourrait être elle merci merci
Monsieur Assouline merci monsieur le
Président je vais mettre autant de temps
que monsieur grosin a posé ma question
euh je je crois que à travers cette
cette
audition il y
a
apparaî la confusion aussi de deux types
de débat le débat sociétal idéologique
sur l'école tel que le pose monsieur
grosin les deux pieds dans le
plat ressassant tout un tas de de
généralités le mérite pour un parti qui
a beaucoup encouragé la rente et et
l'héritage ça parle ça parle dans la
société parce qu'effectivement l'école
n'est pas coupée il y a ce type de débat
on sera jamais d'accord et puis il y a
le débat concret sur cette réforme et je
veux souligner
l'importance fondamentale au collège en
particulier du rôle des chefs
d'établissement dans la vie et la
réussite des
élèves j'ai trois enfants j'ai pu
constater mais ça je l'ai vu à travers
l'ensemble des écoles et des des
collèges de mon
arrondissement que
selon l'équipe dirigeante le collège
était apprécié vivant ou en en en perte
de vitesse et ça pouvait changer dans le
même collège avec la même population
avec les mêmes équipes enseignantes tous
les 3 ans et donc moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est là le concret pas seulement le
débat général et le rôle fondamental que
vous allez avoir Chef Chef de de
d'établissement dans la mise en œuvre et
toutes les questions qui sont posées que
vous avez posé
d'une façon ou d'une autre dans les
difficultés sont les difficultés de la
mise en œuvre d'une réforme on on a
l'expérience sur les
scolaires le débat général sur est-ce
qu'il faut libérer du temps avait été
réglé avait été réglé y compris par
Monsieur châel dans la mise en œuvre on
s'est mis à tout mélanger parce qu'il y
avait forcément une réforme d' si lourde
machine des grandes difficultés de mise
en œuvre de mise en adéquation de
d'adaptation selon les territoires et
cetera et d'un coup c'est mélangé les
deux débats entre les difficultés qu'on
peut pointer et le bien fondé de faire
que il y ait plus de temps
d'apprentissage si on veut mieux réussir
et donc là je je je posz vot questions
s'il vous plaît oui donc la la la la
question c'est
euh pensez-vous que à partir du moment
où le top départ avec un décret été
donné tout ce qui est de votre ressort
comme chef d'établissement pour la mise
en
œuvre notamment la gestion des 20 % la
la la la mise en œuvre concrète de
l'interdisciplinarité et cetera qui qui
interroge qui c'est pas des choses
simple vous pensez que on pourra à la
rentrée de
septembre 2016 être opérationnel pas
peut-être parfaitement mais que c'est
possible
merci Monsieur assouine Madame
duchen non elle est revenue non non elle
est
revenue je je je voulais dire en
préambule que je je n'y croyz pas à ce
qu'on donne la parole
donc en parce que vous l'avez demandé M
chers collèg je ne vois pas qui est le
représentant de l'État dans un
d'établissement il y a le représentant
du
département pour les lycées c'est la
région et pour les écoles c'est donc la
ville alors juste cette petite précision
pour qu' voir plus clair
après ma question rejoint celle de
Monsieur le abat je crois désolé si
j'corche le nom lacchoin parce que dans
la petite autonomie coront les chefs
d'établissement est-ce que il sera
possible en effet
de de prendre une douzaine d'enfants sur
les 3 heures qui seront
interdisciplinaire je ne sais pas si
l'autonomie des principaux
va jusque là et puis enfin quelque chose
aussi que j'avais trouvé de
positif dans la refondation de l'école
c'était le rapprochement et je sais que
Monsieur Carles partageait cet avis
c'était le rapprochement entre l'école
et les 6e dans les collèges comment ce
rapprochement sur le plan pédagogique
pour les disciplines
fondamentales va pouvoir
s'effectuer merci Madame
Cartron oui monsieur le
Président je crois que un des
intervenants a dit cette réforme du
collège c'est une réforme de société et
c'est vrai que cette réforme du collège
elle a pour
ambition de ne plus accepté ce qu'on a
accepté depuis des années c'est-à-dire
que 150000 jeunes du sortent du système
scolaire sans aucune qualification sans
diplôme et soit livré donc après dans
dans la jungle du monde professionnel
sans aucun bagage et sans aucun in tout
donc ça c'est l'ambition de cette
réforme et bien évidemment l'ambition de
cette réformme ou comme ces détracteurs
le disent ce n'est pas de porter
atteinte à l'exc L ou à l'élite parce
que je crois que d'abord les excellents
élèves je dirais presque ils ont presque
pas besoin de l'école parce que comme
vous l'avez dit aussi on apprend en
dehors de l'école mais on apprend aussi
à l'école avec ses pères et donc moi je
voudrais poser une question est-ce que
la principale réforme
euh parce que vous avez parlé des
inégalités sociales qui sont dans les
établissements des et de ces inégalités
scolaires est-ce que la vraie réforme
c'est ne pas
s'attaquer au
recrutement qui se passe dans les
établissements recrutement qui
aujourd'hui conduisent avec en plus
l'assouplissement de la carte scolaire à
des établissements ghetto ghetto dans
les deux sens ghetto soit en recrutement
de
population très favorisé ou getto en
recrutement de population très
défavorisé et bien sûr le dernier
rapport du knesco le dit très clairement
des élèves qui dans des établissements
très défavorisés ne rend compre que 5 %
d'enfants de classe moyenne donc est-ce
que la vraie réforme elle n'est pas là
repenser les modes de recrutement
repenser donc les zones de recrutement
mais aussi repenser à l'intérieur des
établissements le fonctionnement de ce
qui conduit aussi a une ségrégation
entre les classes
donc je pense que nous sommes là à un
premier pas mais je crois que nous
devons nous attaquer à ce qui est une
tâche beaucoup plus
difficile qui sera une vraie mixité une
vraie hétérogénité dans les
établissements parce que toutes les
recherches montrent qu'on apprend mieux
dans l'hétérogénité parce qu'on attend
mieux on apprend mieux à s paè
lorsqu'ils sont différents que
lorsqu'ils sont tous semblables mais
merci Madame
Blondin merci monsieur le Président
avant j'ai deux questions mais avant
cela je voudrais souligner l'importance
de ce qui a été dit par une
représentante des chefs d'établissement
à savoir la stabilité des équipes et ça
c'est vrai qu'il est important pour
pouvoir
assurer le le fruit finalement de la
mise en place de ces pratiques nouvelles
qu'il y ait une certaine continuité or
on sait euh chacun d'entre nous savons
ici sa ici pardon que la gestion des
ressources humaines au niveau du
ministère est parfois fort compliqué et
il y a encore des améliorations à
apporter euh une une question
s'adressant aux chefs d'établissement et
euh concernant le conseil pédagogique
euh il y a des craintes de la part
d'enseignants de voir le poids du chef
d'établ
qui présidera ce conseil
pédagogique porté sur le choix des EPI
c'est-à-dire qu'il aura peut-être
tendance et je voudrais savoir leur avis
à choisir avec les équipes enseignante
bien sûr mais à apporté son poids
décisif dans la sélection desep desepis
au détriment peut-être
d'autres pays tels que je pense
évidemment aux langues et culture
régionales qui sont des points
importants pour l'enseignement des
langues régionales et qui vont se
retrouver en concurrence avec d'autres
pays donc il y a ces enseignants sont
véritablement inquiets de voir la le
choix qui va pouvoir être donné surtout
que les enseignants de ces langues
régionales sont parfois euh détaché sur
plusieurs établissements et ont
peut-être un moins de poids pour pouvoir
agir sur dans ce conseil pédagogique
et une autre question qui concerne les
inspections c'est véritablement
l'élaboration de la nouvelle carte des
langues vivantes qui va se mettre en
place pour la fin la fin de l'année et
qui va présenter évidemment euh
les les langues offertes dans le secteur
donné et j'insiste bien entendu euh
auprès des rectorats mais également
auprès des inspections
académiques de la nécessité de prendre
en compte ces langues régionales qui
viennent d'être reprises par le
Président de la République pour la
ratification de la Charte minoritaire
des
langues merci Madame Blondin
permettez-moi mes ch collègue de saluer
la présence dans les tribunes de
fonctionnaires du Sénat italien et de
leur souhaiter en votre nom la plus
amicale bienvenue au Sénat français
monsieur
Savin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs euh d'ord merci
d'avoir participé à cette table ronde et
puis de nous avoir donné un peu votre
point vue nous avons bien entendu vous
avons
entendu parler d'organisation
d'autonomie de travail de contenu des
enseignement de formation mais par
contre il y a un point ce qui n'a pas
été abordé je suis assez surpris qu'un
chef d'établissement les représentants
des chefs d'établissement les pas abordé
parce que sur le terrain lorsque nous
sommes et ça se produit de plus en plus
des chefs d'établissements que nous
rencontrons nous parle d'un problème
récurrent dans les collèges c'est un
problème de sécurité de discipline or
aujourd'hui si on veut assurer aussi des
enseignements qui
soient de qualité il faut aussi assurer
dans ses établissements dans ses
collèges garanti que tous les élèves et
les enseignants puissent assurer leur
cours de façon
euh pérenne mais surtout avec une
garantie de pouvoir le faire en en toute
sécurité et euh il y a une problématique
que les les les chefs d'établissement
rencontre c'est les élèves qui sont en
situation de rupture qui sont
parfois avec à l'issue des conseils de
discipline expulsés des collèges et qui
sont rescolarisé dans le collège voisin
et puis ça va durer jusqu'à la fin de la
scolarité j'ai rencontré encore
récemment une chef d'établissement une
une principale qui vient nous solliciter
nous les maires pour régler ces
problèmes qui sont parfois à l'intérieur
mais aussi à l'extérieur du collège et
euh j'ai pas senti euh j'ai pas vu dans
le dans les propos de la ministre
entendu dans les propos de la ministre
mais aussi dans le dans ce projet de de
réforme mais aussi aujourd'hui dans
cette dans les explications que vous
avez donné ce point qui est élaboré qui
me paraît assez important bien sûr qu'il
faut
euh aborder tous les autres sujets mais
ce sujet là me me paraît important en ce
qui concerne la discipline et la
sécurité des enseignants et des élèves
dans dans ces
établissements merci madame
Monier monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues tout d'abord dire à Monsieur
Richard qui a comparé le président d'un
conseil d'administration d'un collège
avec un maire un maire il est élu par
ses citoyens et par un conseil municipal
et parfois souvent aussi dans un conseil
d'administration je crois qu'il y a une
élection alors peut-être qu'il faut lui
donner un autre nom voir mais voilà je
sais pas si c'est une bonne comparaison
et je connais enfin je sais que pour les
chefs d'établissement c'est souvent un
écart tellement entre voilà c'est une
position délicate vous avez par je crois
que c'est Monsieur Duvin de de
l'ambition la même pour tous pour nos
élèves je crois que c'est important
parce qu'il faut aussi se rappeler
qu'avant dans les collèges quand il y
avait les filières c'était un gros
problème parce que les enfants se
révélaient au cours du collège et qu'ils
étaient enfermés dans une filière et que
c'était dur pour eux après de s'en
sortir je pense qu'il est très important
de tenir compte des élèves que nous
avons en face de nous du niveau de leurs
compétences de leurs capacités et
adapter notre pédagogie la faire
différencier pour répondre au besoins
c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont en
difficultés bien sûr les aider et on est
tous d'accord sur la nécessité C d'une
réforme justement qui part du constat
que beaucoup d'élèves en difficulté
sortent du collège normalement enfin
malheureusement excusez-moi pas
normalement soit sans qualifi sans voie
professionnelle qui leur correspond soit
sans sans diplôme j'étais contente
justement d'entendre parler un petit peu
d'effectif parce que c'est vrai qu'on ne
résoudra pas tout avec les effectifs
mais que c'est très important que la
plupart des classes sont très
hétérogènes et que justement dans ce
cas-là si les classes sont trop chargées
ce sont les enfants qui sont en
difficulté qui sont pénalisés il faut en
effet réchir comment on les on les aide
ma question portait sur le brevet à
titre personnel je pense que c'est une
bonne chose le brevet parce que quand on
le passe en tant qu'examen parce que
c'est la première fois que les élèves
passent un examen et est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas c'était ma question réfléchir à
son devenir mais en fonction de l'après
moi il me semblait que cé important
qu'il puisse passer cet examen parce
qu'après il y a le bac où il y a un
enjeu vraiment beaucoup plus important
que le brevet où là il y a un choix de
poursuite de scolarité qui se fait ou
non alors que dans le brevet n'y était
pas ceci dit il y a la validation des
compétences qui est importante mais qui
se fait à l'heure actuelle puisqueil y a
le livré de compétences qu'on valide et
que le brevet ben c'est un examen qui
permet de voir un petit peu où on en est
face à la notion d'examen voilà qu'en
pensez-vous par rapport à voir ça plus
globalement que juste voir l'examen le
brevet de fin de collège voir dans la
poursuite de la scolarité
merci merci Madame
Jouve oui merci monsieur le Président je
partage complètement l'idée de Monsieur
rouagac sur le fait que l'éducation ne
se fait pas seulement au collège par
contre je crois qu'il est nécessaire de
prendre en compte la vie des collégiens
dans leur globalité c'est-à-dire leurs
conditions d'accueil au collège puisque
la journée d'un collégien ne se résume
pas aux enseignement mais ce qui
concerne la vie scolaire le transport la
restauration la sécurité comme le disait
monsieur Savin ma question concerne une
catégorie d'enseignant spécifique que
sont les professeurs documentalistes
leur rôle il me semble sembletil
important dans la mise en place des
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaires pouvez-vous
m'indiquer si une réflexion a été engagé
au sujet de la place des centres de
documentation et d'information dans les
collèges je rejoins d'ailleurs
complètement la remarque de Monsieur
rouagac sur la nécessité de former les
élèves à l'utilisation d'Internet et
c'est déjà la mission des
CDI merci qui commence la série de
réponse à ces différentes
questions monsieur Richard comm je il en
faut un alors il y a une question sur le
doublement n'est-il pas une une chance
notre réponse c'est est CLA c'est non
pour une raison simple c'est que le
doublement s'il ne se fait ne s'effectue
pas dans une modification prop profonde
des des méthode pédagogique fait que
l'élève qui a échoué une première année
se retrouve confronté au même dispositif
et donc bien évidemment le le le le
système n'ayant pas fonctionné en
première instance ne fonctionnera pas en
2e instance évolution quelle évolution
sur la réforme et ben bien évidemment
que elle elle permettent une mise en
œuvre rapide euh pour que nous puissions
répondre aux besoins de notre société et
plusieurs de vos interlocuteurs ont mis
en évidence le fait que nous formions
les citoyens de demain et que donc là
nous avons tous une responsabilité à
partager euh qu'est-ce qu' les alors les
questions sur les les effectifs euh nous
pensons que ce sont plutôt les méthodes
pédagogiques qui ont d'importance plutôt
que les effectifs or dans ce domaine on
a par exemple les fonctionnements en
groupe de besoin où on fait on rassemble
trois classes et on met quatre
enseignants qui permet effectivement une
individualisation et c'est C
individualisation qui est tout à fait pr
préférable parce que en jouant
simplement sur les effectifs on on va
être confronté à ce que mon collègue
disait tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire à des
problèmes matériel de dimension des
établissements ils ont été conçus à une
certaine époque avec des normes et on ne
déplace pas les murs nous le nous le
savons bien
euh en ce qui concerne sécurité et
discipline les chefs d'établissement que
nous sommes mais bien évidemment nous y
sommes très attachés mais nous savons
depuis les travaux menés entre autres
par éic de bieux que c'est en
travaillant sur le climat de
l'établissement que l'on fait avancer
cette question et nous nous pensons
qu'il est effectivement toujours
préférable parce que nous sommes des
pédagogues d'être dans une démarche où
l'on va convaincre plutôt que
contraindre bien évidemment ne jamais
renoncer à sanctionner lorsque la
démarche de conviction n'a pas
fonctionné et puis sur le brevet je
répéterai ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
nous pensons que il n'a plus sa raison
d'être aujourd'hui aujourd'hui avec la
validation du socle commun à l'issue de
la classe de 3e et que par ailleurs pour
les élèves ils auront tout le temps
lorsqu'ils seront au baccalauréat en
lycée de préparer le baccalauréat et que
cette épreuve qui s'est complexifié
parce que je rappelle qu'elle comprend
une période un temps de contrôle continu
trois épreuves terminales des épreuves
ponctuell avec l'épr d'histoire des arts
la validation de compétences fait que
c'est une organisation très lourde pour
les établissements avec un nombre
considérable d'heures de cours qui sont
qui ne peuvent pas être assurés du fait
de l'organisation de ces épreuves et
nous pensons que il est très nettement
préférable pour les élèves de bénéficier
d'heors d'enseignement que de se
disperser sur un diplôme qui d'ailleurs
ne débouche sur rien puisque'il ne
détermine pas la poursuite d'études en
seconde générale ou en seconde
professionnelle et que bien évidemment
c'est la validation par le conseil de
classe qui est recherché par les élèves
plutôt que la réussite au Brevet merci
merci j'avais oublié notre collègue
monsieur Kenel qui a une question à
poser
oui merci Président c'est vrai que je
suis un peu excentré donc et que tu
n'aimes pas trop l'extrême droite tu as
raison d'ailleurs
euh j'ai une petite question poil à
gratter par rapport au aux personnes qui
ont bien voulu venir aujourd'hui vous
êtes des couras de transmission vous
faites partie de la hiérarchie de
l'éducation nationale comment se fait-il
que euh nous constatons que il y a
quasiment 74 % des enseignants qui sont
opposés à cette réforme ou qui se
déclarent opposé certes c'est qu'un
sondage euh est-ce que finalement cette
courroie de transmission entre le
ministère les inspection les directions
et les enseignants cette courroie de
transmission fonctionne est-ce que cette
réforme a été mal expliquée aux
enseignants euh si euh elle elle est
utile et je crois qu'elle a une certaine
utilité ça c'est ma première question la
la deuxième question c'est je ne vous ai
pas entendu parler d'orientation certes
il y a un module pays euh initiation à
la vie économique mais s'il n'est pas
choisi euh dans un établissement est-ce
que euh l'orientation met une croix
dessus merci Monsieur Kenel qui veut
répondre à cette question et aux
précédentees madame
paayette euh ben je vais peut-être
profiter déjà sur la courroie de
transmission des personnels de direction
par rapport à la réforme euh il me
semble difficile que les personnels de
direction
euh expliquent déjà la réforme alors que
les textes sont en à peine en cours de
publication et que d'autre part il y a
quand même eu dans le dans la vague
médiatique euh dans l'ensemble de la de
de la sphère publique euh une série de
je le je le redis de désinformations de
de de de réalité tordu qui peut
expliquer que lors d'un sondage des
personnels se prononcent sur une forte
inquiétude quand quand effectivement il
y a eu beaucoup de désinformations d'où
je renouvelle effectivement de notre
point de vue l'importance dans
l'établissement dans les collèges dès
cette fin d'année d'avoir un temps
d'appropriation de la réforme de de
profiter de la fin d'année pour que les
personnels de direction qui ne sont pas
que des courroiss de transmission mais
qui sont bien les représentants de
l'État dans les collèges non mais qui
sont don je répondais à la question il y
avait une question de quelqu'un qui
demandait qui étaient les représentants
de l'État dans les établissements
scolaires ce sont bien les personnels de
direction qui sont le bout de la chaîne
hiérarchique mais effectivement on est
la chaîne hiérarchique et en même temps
on on doit organiser impulser organiser
le le le travail collectif moi je je
confirme tout à fait enfin je j'ai
exactement la même opinion que mon
collègue de du snpdn sur le
redoublement refaire la même chose dans
les mêmes conditions ne sert à rien
c'est bien pour ça que nous nous sommes
farouchement partisans d'une progression
en cycle c'est-à-dire où l'élève est
évalué à la fin oou l'évaluation
définitive sommative pour employer un
mot technique euh arrive à la fin du
cycle avant on fait des essais on fait
des essais on fait des erreurs on ne
fait pas des fautes d'ailleurs on fait
des erreurs on se trompe et c'est la
c'est c'est le fait de se tromper qui va
permettre de se construire et
l'expérience que j'ai eu dans trois
collèges différents quand on fait
l'analyse des redoublement à résultat à
peu près égal quand on regarde les
élèves ceux qui ont redoublé parce qu'à
une époque le redoublement est accepté
ou pas par les familles donc il y a des
il y a il y a des quand on a le
redoublement on dit bah oui là ok on
écoute l'argument on va plutôt le faire
redoubler ou pas le faire redoubler on
se rend compte que des élèves qui à
niveau égal l'un a redoublé l'autre a
progressé à la fin des courses c'est
plutôt celui qui est resté dans sa
classe d'âge qui a fait le plus de
progrès enfin ça c'est très net quand on
fait des études un petit peu de suivi de
coohorte sur les établissements et voilà
pourquoi nous effectivement le
redoublement n'est n'est véritablement
pas la solution mais véritablement par
contre la progression en cycle sur
l'ensemble du collège euh sur les sur
les effectifs et les petits groupes
effectivement la le les marges horaires
qui sont donné dans le cadre de la
réforme les les marges horaires qui sont
donné aux établissements qui sont de de
mémoire pour un collège pour un collège
de 20 classes qui qui correspondent à à
peu près la première année de de mise en
place à si mes souvenirs sont bon 55 he
par semaine et 60 he la la suivante
permet tout de même d'organiser à des
moments précis des des apprentissage en
plus petit groupe en groupe restreint ou
de faire intervenir deux professeurs
dans avec la avec le même groupe d'
il nous semble que c'est bien préférable
à une réflexion assez dogmatique sur les
effectifs sur l'ensemble d'une classe
pour avoir enseigné l'histoire et
géographie en collège ZEP il y a très
longtemps à à Denin je me souviens que
j'avais été chargé enfin j'avais accepté
de prendre la classe à effectif réduit
qu'on avait fait dans le collège pour
mettre les élèves qui avaient plus de
difficultés ben je veux dire que c'est
une expérience qui me fait dire très
clairement que de mettre ensemble dans
la même classe même s'ils sont pas
nombreux tous les élèves qui ont des
difficultés ne permet pas de créer une
dynamique propice à l'apprentissage et
je voudrais revenir ce que ce que sur ce
que disait madame gartron sur le le
l'importance effectivement de la
réflexion autour du recrutement et de la
carte scolaire je l'ai dit dans une
autre instance c'était à l'Assemblée
nationale dans l'évaluation des
politiques sur la mixité sociale il nous
semble effectivement qu'il est
absolument urgent de travailler sur la
mixité sociale mais encore une fois
c'est pas le sujet de la réforme du
collège et si on parle de
l'apprentissage avec les paires la le
l'intérêt je voudrais revenir sur ces
questions de l'excellence et et de on
donne plus à ceux qui ont moins mais il
faut pas faut continuer à donner plus à
ceux qui ont plus enfin je caricature un
petit peu mais c'est un petit peu le
sens de ce qu'on a pu entendre beaucoup
dans dans dans les médias
euh les élèves apprennent effectivement
beaucoup en dehors de l'école et ceux
qui apprennent le plus en dehors de
l'école ce sont les élèves les plus
favorisés donc mobilisons véritablement
le les le le le les moyens de l'école à
ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin ça c'est
c'est une conviction que nous avons et
d'autre part il est bien plus
intéressant y compris pour des élèves
qui sont de bons élèves de pouvoir être
dans la dans le travail avec leurs père
parce que parfois euh pouvoir reformuler
avoir organiser des des séances où on
mélange où on a des élèves en difficulté
des élèves qui sont meilleurs je veux
dire que le meilleur devient meilleur
parce qu'il explique au plus difficile
au plus plus en difficulté et ça ça me
semble aussi quelque chose qui doit
permettre de construire avec nos élèves
avec l'ensemble de nos élèves les les
les la la condition de la solidarité de
la coopération ce qui est désolant dans
un établissement scolaire c'est quand
effectivement dans les relations entre
entre élèves on entend certains traiter
les autres d'intellectuels parce qu'ils
ils sont représentés comme les plus
favorisés et il y a une une détest des
détestations qui s'installent voire des
question de harcèlement parce que
systématiquement on est dans la dans
dans dans le dans l'émulation même pas
dans l'émulation dans la compétition et
dans le et dans la concurrence
organisons dans nos collèges des des des
modes de fonctionnement entre élèves où
on est dans la coopération et on
changera effectivement le climat
scolaire parce que les élèves qui vont
pas bien les élèves qui sont en
situation de rupture dont on nous parle
que on sait pas quoi en faire
effectivement on leur doit la
scolarisation mais s'ils sont dans cet
état c'est aussi bien souvent parce
qu'ils ont un vécu scolaire et un vécu
d'exclusion à l'intérieur de l'école qui
est absolument insupportable pour eux et
c'est en travaillant sur cette exclusion
interne à l'école qu'on pourra
véritablement aussi leur redonner de
l'espoir et de la confiance envers les
adultes et envers leurs camarades enfin
je crois qu'il y a si c'est difficile
dans certains établissements c'est aussi
cette relation pédagogique exclusif qui
tourne vers la construction de la
compétition je reviendrai pas sur les
questions de la notation où on se paye
les en disant de la la démagogie de pas
mettre de notes non si on si on évalue
les élèves sur leurs progrès plutôt que
sur leur manque on leur donne aussi de
la confiance et on rétablit de la
sérénité dans les établissements
scolaires ça c'est quelque chose aussi
sur lequel nous sommes extrêmement
attachés voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
cette table ronde autour de la réforme
du collège alors que plus de 12 millions
d'élèves font leur grande rentrée
scolaire aujourd'hui vous pouvez revoir
bien sûr ce programme sur notre site
internet
publicsenat.fr
e